Ja, schon instant 21 Leute da, wie kommt ihr denn so schnell her?
Sub box gekämpft oder schmal excess point am start
Warum bankierst du und kopierst du immer einzelne Buchstaben?
Das ist so ein Tick, den ich schon seit ein paar Jahren habe.
Nicht, dass es irgendwie sinnvoll wäre, das zu machen.
Ich glaube, wir haben da sogar irgendeinen Clip mal aufgenommen als Erklärung.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1 im Chat. Ausgeschrieben 1, nicht die Zahl.
Ja, da gibt es glaube ich sogar eine Erklärung zu.
Naja, ist halt so. Irgendwie habe ich mir das angewöhnt.
Stimmt, heute ist ja Ostern. Ganz vergessen und wird ja auferstanden.
Also, dann gucken wir mal eine Sache, die wir immer morgens gucken, sonntags.
Und zwar, was sind denn die Github Trends von dieser Woche?
Und ich predicte es jetzt schon mal wieder. Es ist wieder AI und fast ausschließlich AI.
Also, Twitter Algorithmus. Algorithmus, muss man ja sagen, ist ja nicht Rhythmus, es ist Rhythmus.
Wahrscheinlich auch AI. Unleashed-Filme, das hat nichts mit meinen Axis Points zu tun,
oder? Das ist eher was für einen 3D-Drucker. Was genau bin ich sehend? Was ist das?
Ich habe legit keine Ahnung. Was ist das? Was für, was für Funk-Dinger, oder?
Das ist so ein typischer Fall von, ich gucke die Github-Seite an, ich habe absolut keine Ahnung,
was es ist. Was ist denn ein, ach, das ist diese, jetzt weiß ich, das ist dieses USB-Wi-Fi-Hack-Ding,
oder? Jajaja, ok. Jetzt, ok, da ist, jetzt. AI, AI und AI, nice. Es gab irgendwie doch zwei
Sachen, die nicht AI waren, toll. Also, die Github-Trends sind dieses Mal wirklich,
mein, guckt mal. Selbst, selbst, wenn man hier mal zurückgeht auf diesen Monat. Das ist ja nur
noch AI komplett. A I A I A I. AI AI AI AI AI AI AI AI AI AI AI... diesen Monat ist nur AI trending.
Visual Chat-GPT. Das klingt sehr nach China-Chinesen-Chat-GPT. Und selbst wenn das UI heißt,
nein, es ist AI. Das muss eigentlich Q-Gui heißen. AI, ja. Also, das muss man sagen. Das hält
sich wirklich. Okay, wir müssen noch mal, lass mal eine Sache gucken. Wir schränken das mal kurz ein.
Language. Nehm' mal Massey Sharp. Da gibt's nicht viele Repos. Da gibt's nicht viele Repos,
die trenden. Deswegen, mal gucken, was da trendet über den Monat. Chat-GPT. Chat-GPT-klein. Okay,
nice. Avalonia-OI. Chat-GPT-klein. Da kann ich doch aber auch genauso gut im... also, ich mein,
wenn ich so was auf dem Desktop habe, dann kann ich doch... wichtig, Karl Klammer ist auch am
Start. Da kann ich doch einfach in den Browser gehen und es da drüber verwenden. Also, den Sinn
von solchen Desktop-Kleins, außer dass es bestimmt cool ist, so was zu erstellen, sehe ich nicht so
ganz. Das ist auch AI. Ich weiß nicht genau, was es ist, um ehrlich zu sein, was X-Ray Core und
V2Fly ist, aber wenn ich raten müsste, würde ich sagen, AI? V2Fly. Ach nee, nein. Es ist,
okay, China-Chinesen-Zeug, um die China-Firewall zu umgehen, ist es. Okay. AI. China-Chinesen-Hacker-Hackerman-Zeug.
Ah ja, gut. Bei .NET bzw. bei C-Sharp trenden natürlich auch relativ viele Unity-Projekte.
Es trendet ein DNS-Server? Bei. Okay. Na dann.
Lieber Hardware-Monitor. Okay, das ist, glaube ich, das erste halbwegs gescheite Projekt,
was ich heute auf GitHub gesehen habe. Also, was mich interessiert. Das haben wir, glaube ich,
sogar mal benutzt als Library. Das haben wir mal benutzt, um ein FPS-Counter zu bauen, glaube ich.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Temperaturauferlay. Blow-Lounge. Osu! Natürlich. Was sollte auch sonst
unter C-Sharp trenden? Osu, natürlich. Muss natürlich sein. Na gut. Die .NET Trends sind
zumindest nicht ganz so langweilig wie die Haupt-Twitter-Trends. Okay, wenn ihr wollt,
kann man machen. Schauen wir mal. Was trendet in Go? Ah, ich hab' Go. AI. Ich hab' keine Ahnung,
was das sein soll. A rule-based tunnel. Hat das irgendwas mit VPN zu tun? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ah, doch. Irgendwie Fake-VPN-Zeug. A cloud-native-vector-database. Storage for
next-generation AI-Applications. Ja gut, was auch sonst. Jetzt brauchen AI-Applications schon
ihre eigene Tatbank. Okay, hat bestimmt seinen Sinn. China-Chinesen-Zeug. Keine Ahnung. Noch
mehr China-Chinesen-Zeug. Ein cloud-native-monitoring-system. Ein drop-in-replacement von Prometheus. Okay,
warum exakt muss man Prometheus ersetzen? Ich hatte eigentlich von Prometheus immer einen
guten Eindruck bisher. Aber es ist China-Chinesen-Zeug. Wahrscheinlich ist es nicht China-Chinesen genug,
das Original Prometheus. Also ich weiß nicht. Ich finde die Kombination Prometheus plus
Grafana eventuell Alert-Manager, wenn man das in dem Kontext braucht. Man kann ja auch Prometheus
benutzen und die Metriken woanders dann wieder abgreifen. Und Grafana eigentlich eine super
Kombination, die sehr etabliert ist. Aktiv weiterentwickelt wird. Große Community. Also
ich wüsste nicht so genau. Warum? Ah, nice. Ein China-Chinesen-UI. Gut.
Das mag ja ganz cool sein, aber ich hoffe mal, man kann die Oberfläche auch auf Englisch umstellen.
Hast du Unity auf deiner To-Do-List? Nee. Game-Entwicklung interessiert mich tatsächlich
gar nicht groß. Okay, warum man das braucht, schließt sich mir aktuell noch nicht. Gut,
wenn man mehrere Collector-Sachen verwendet, nicht nur die Prometheus. Ja, mag vielleicht
sinnvoll sein, aber ich bin immer ein bisschen skeptisch bei China-Produkten, selbst wenn sie
Open Source auf GitHub sind. Auch ein China-Chinesen-Zeug. Ein Blockchain-Gedöns. Endlich
mal was Gutes, was trendet. Nice. Wobei das ja mittlerweile auch in einer Firma in Hongkong gehört.
Ja, das ist auch was Gutes. GitHub-Actions-Lokal.
Das ist auch nice. Das lohnt sich echt zu installieren. Kann man ab und zu mal gebrauchen.
Wie, es gibt eine ordentliche Link-Style-Goal-Library mittlerweile. Mit Generics. Die Goal-Generics
sind ja auch so ein bisschen Paints-Champ. Zeig mal her, wie sieht denn das aus?
Example. Alter, die Goal-Generics sind so hässlich, man.
Klingt ja ehrlich gesagt erst mal relativ sinnvoll. Geben wir mal einen Stern. Nee,
ich bin gar nicht eingeloggt. Geben wir keinen Stern. Ich kopiere mir das mal raus. Das kann
man sich wahrscheinlich echt mal angucken, wenn man Go-Stalls macht. So, also das war's
mal go. Und jetzt das allermost important überhaupt. Wie sehen die Trends in Rust aus?
Weil wir müssen Blazingly fast written in Rust sein. Erspack haben wir am Start. Das
habe ich schon mal gesehen. Das ist irgendeine Webpack-Alternative für in Rust. Gut, Webpack
ist auch abartig. Die coolen Leute verwenden ja Veed seit schon einer ganzen Weile, aber
anscheinend gibt es jetzt noch Erspack, was noch neuer, cooler und Blazingly fast ist.
Der Name Erspack ist halt ein bisschen, bisschen dumm. Fast Startup Lightning. Hot Module Replacement.
Ich finde es interessant, dass die mittlerweile Abkürzungen verwenden, so als müsste jeder
auf der Welt wissen, was HMR ist. Leute, war euch klar, dass HMR Hot Module Replacement ist?
Ich weiß, das ist zufällig, weil ich so Sachen schon mal benutzt habe. Aber ich
weiß, ich glaube nicht, dass das allgemein Wissen ist. Okay, noch weiteres Cross-Platform-UI.
Taugt das? Example. Okay, sieht mega advanced aus. Bissle aus wie 1995.
Das sieht aus wie auf meinem Drucker.
Das sind GTK Widgets, oder? Das ist wieder irgendein Rapper und die malen ihre Controls nicht selbst.
Malen die ihre Controls selbst?
Ach, tatsächlich die malen ihre Controls selbst.
Ah ne, das ist ein Aufsatz auf Qt, oder was?
Vielleicht gar nicht mal so blöd. Klingt eigentlich relativ interessant. Es gibt viel zu wenig gute
UI-Frameworks, die sich auf Native-Anwendungen spezialisiert haben. Deswegen haben wir ja
heutzutage jede zweite Anwendung im Browser oder Elektron. Da ist heute auch ein Texteditor
oder ein Notizprogramm. Erst mal 800 MB RAM beim Starten braucht. Okay, Chat-GPT, was sonst?
Das hatten wir schon, keine Ahnung. No FWL Desktop Application. Was soll das sein?
Nice. Erkennt man schon was? Okay, AI. Was sonst? Im Zweifelsfall, wenn man nicht weiß, was es ist, AI.
Texteditor, AI. Westorm, endlich mal was Gutes. Poggers. Bestes Terminal.
Syntax Highlighting-Gedöns. Web-Framework. Wobei ich immer noch nicht so genau checke, warum man das in Rust machen möchte.
Aber gibt bestimmt seinen Anwendungszweck. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll. Apache Open Dull.
Exist data freely painlessly and efficient. Wenn das nicht Placingly fast geht, dann will ich das nicht.
Ah, okay. Das ist irgend so ein API Gateway für Storage. Sowas in der Richtung, würde ich jetzt mal vermuten.
Also wenn man nicht explizit S3 machen will, nicht explizit Redis machen will, kann man Open Dull machen und da alles drauf zugreifen oder so.
Okay, ja, warum nicht?
Cairo. Cairo heißt glaube ich auch das GTK 2D Mal Library. Aber das war was anderes.
Reakt, Like und dann in Rust. Das ist eine Kombination. Das ist beide schon nicht schön zu programmieren und das in Kombination.
Ich finde an dem Beispiel sieht man schon, dass Rust einen anderen Anwendungszweck hat.
Ich meine, das hier mag ja alles nice sein, wenn man möglichst safe and cold haben will in einer nicht managet Umgebung.
Okay, aber für UI Libraries bzw. für UIs zu bauen, weiß ich nicht, ob der hohe Rauschanteil von Rust in der Sprache da jetzt gerade förderlich ist.
Also ich habe quasi JSX mit irgendwie Rust Makros nachgebaut. Blazingly fast, selbstverständlich. Es ist ja auch in Rust, was sonst?
Unter 3MB Binaries. Okay, das ist natürlich nice für UI Anwendungen.
Eigentlich klingt das auch ganz cool. Blöd, dass man das in Rust programmieren muss.
Flash Player in Rust.
Für die ganzen Legacy Flash Games.
WebAssembly.
Okay, das stelle ich mir tatsächlich sogar ganz praktisch vor.
Wenn man wissen will, wo.
Ich glaube, das probiere ich mal aus. Das, das erscheint mir tatsächlich sogar ganz sinnvoll, wenn man wissen will, wo, wie groß welche Files sind, wo sich besonders viel Mist angesammelt hat. Ja, das könnte man, das, das speichere ich mir mal.
Discord AP.
Web Framework.
Magic Shell History.
Mit einer Schildkröte, okay.
Artween ist bestimmt eine Schildkröte in irgendeiner Sprache.
Was soll das sein?
Magical Shell History.
Okay, replaces your existing Shell History.
Ist nicht wirklich, oder?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das so ist.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich das so gut finde.
So eine Textdatei durch eine SQLite-Datenbank zu ersetzen an einer Stelle, wo es nun wirklich keine Performance-Probleme gibt.
Okay, man kann seine Shell-Historie synchronisieren lassen. Das ist in der Tat ganz cool.
Ich wüsste bisher noch nicht, ob ich das gebraucht habe, hätte oder nicht.
Aber das klingt nach einem nice, wobei man das theoretisch ja auch...
Wobei, na, Shell-Historie synchronisieren ist ein bisschen komplizierter.
Weil du ja oftmals parallel auf zwei Systemen was machst.
Okay.
Könnte eine coole Sache sein.
Ich weiß aber echt nicht, ob ich es so cool finde, meine Shell-Historie Textdatei durch eine SQLite-Datenbank zu ersetzen.
Ich mag eigentlich das Standardverhalten von der Shell, wenn man Ctrl-R drückt und die History durchsucht.
Ich hatte eine ganze Weile, habt ihr ja auch im Stream gesehen, dieses FZF Plugin für die History.
Dass ich eben meine Shell-Historie nicht einfach nur mit Ctrl-R durchsuchen konnte, sondern auch so Fuzzy-Search hatte.
Das habe ich mittlerweile wieder ausgeschaltet, weil es mich genervt hat.
Weil man oftmals Sachen gefunden hat, wo die Buchstaben drin vorkamen, die man gar nicht finden wollte.
Also weiß ich nicht.
Also ich hatte das ja lange Zeit so.
Okay, Passwort liegt, Leute.
Gebt zu, ohne dass ich geleakt hätte, das Passwort hätte ihr wahrscheinlich nie erraten.
Ich benutze prinzipiell nur Best-Practice-Passwörter.
Und ich meine absichtlich nicht Best-Practice zur Passwort-Erstellung, sondern ich benutze nur verbreitete Passwörter.
Weil umso verbreiteter die sind, umso besser sind sie natürlich, weil alles was verbreitet ist, muss gut sein.
Logisch.
Also ich hatte ja die ganze Zeit lang als History sowas hier in der Richtung.
Ich mache das jetzt einfach mal.
Ja, da konnte man seine History durchsuchen.
Also da gibt es so ein offizielles Plugin.
Dann konnte man hier drin Zeug suchen.
Das Dumme ist nur, wenn man hier irgendwie Zeug sucht.
Was hat denn hier im Gleich?
Wenn man hier drin was sucht, man findet manchmal auch Dinge, die man gar nicht finden will.
Weil es halt zufälligerweise drin vorkommt.
Ja guck, manchmal suchst du das jetzt hier ein gutes Beispiel.
Du suchst nach was und erfindet auf einmal hier solche Dinge.
Das ist ja richtig, weil die Sachen kommen drin vor.
Aber die will ich in der History eigentlich gar nicht haben.
Und ich habe es nicht gescheit hinbekommen, das ordentlich zu konfigurieren.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt wieder mein stinknormales History Search.
So wie man das seit Jahrzehnten unter Linux hat.
Und das funktioniert für mich immer noch am besten.
So und ob ich jetzt meine Shell History durch eine SQLite Datenbank ersetzen will?
Ich weiß nicht, vor allem so wirklich großartig was davon haben tut man ja auch nicht.
Man kann jetzt suchen, wann man was gemacht hat.
Okay, das ist ganz sinnvoll.
Aber meistens hält es sich ja in Grenzen.
Und man kann da einfach drüber scrollen.
Okay, mag in manchen Fällen sinnvoll sein, ob ich das...
Ah, ich weiß nicht.
Ich bin mir da nicht so ganz sicher.
Wartet mal.
So.
Moin Max.
Hab heute Nacht ein Video gesehen mit dem Emulator und dem Bartosera System.
Ja, nice.
Ich bin mir da nicht sicher, ob man das System auf einem Routeserver laufen zu lassen.
Und sich quasi ein Clouds System damit erstellen will.
Nee, wahrscheinlich.
Zumindest so out of the box nicht.
Du musst ja irgendwie dein Input hinbekommen.
Und dein Output, was das Ding rendert zurück.
Es gibt ein paar Low Latency Streaming Options.
Frag mich jetzt bitte nicht nach dem Namen.
Ich hab das vor ein paar Jahren mal mit dem Famian zusammen gemacht.
Als wir noch BDO gespielt haben.
Da wir teilweise BDO Low Latency rüber gestreamt.
Aber für Linux fällt mir jetzt da so spontan gar nichts ein.
Gibt es aber bestimmt.
Aber ich glaube nicht, dass es den Aufwand wert ist.
Weil wie gesagt.
Du musst dein Controller Input irgendwie da hin übertragen.
Du brauchst ja lokal immer noch was.
Wo du.
Dein Controller anstöpselst und hinschickst.
Und die meisten Emulator gerade für die älteren Systeme.
Die laufen wahrscheinlich auf diese alten Kiste.
Wo du deinen Controller anstöpselst auch.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ich sage nicht, dass es nicht geht.
Aber ich glaube es ist den Aufwand nicht wert.
Falls es gescheit funktioniert.
Tja.
Es ist immer noch geplant.
Mehr kann ich nicht sagen.
Ob sich das mal ergibt in nächster Zeit.
Weiß ich nicht.
Das kann das iPhone 15 Pro.
Da bin ich tatsächlich mal gespannt drauf.
Weil ich hab mir erst ein iPhone 14 gekauft.
So.
Okay.
Nice so.
Gut.
So Leute.
So.
Ich habe jetzt den iPhone 14 gekauft.
Also.
Sofern.
Vielleicht.
Okay.
Nice so.
Gut.
Was gucken wir uns denn jetzt an?
Also was ich benutzt habe damals.
Um Low Latency Streaming zu machen.
Mit dem Fabian zusammen.
Das war.
Parsec hieß das glaube ich.
Das könnte sogar das gewesen sein.
Das konnte man damals selbst hosten.
Ich weiß nicht ob das noch funktioniert.
Ach Self Hosting gibt es nicht mehr.
Okay.
Ja.
F.
Wie gut hausten unter Linux ging ja noch nie damit.
Aber unter Windows.
Also früher ging das vor ein paar Jahren noch.
Da habe ich das benutzt mit dem Fabian zusammen.
Moonlight ist der Nachbau von.
diesem Nvidia Streaming.
Was ist das?
Decentralize Self Host Cloud Gaming.
Application.
Ja gut.
Diablo und Starcraft das ist jetzt nicht so wirklich.
Das ist.
Die Killer Games sind die man heute da übertragen muss.
Ich würde fast vermuten es gibt nichts gescheites.
Left WM.
Nein haben wir noch nicht angeguckt.
Über EA und Battlefield.
Okay das gucken wir uns an.
Das ist ein gutes Einstiegsvideo.
Das gucken wir uns an.
Das hatte ich eh schon offen.
Das macht auch immer gute Videos.
Wo ist es denn?
Hier das da.
Erik Dankeschön für den Sub.
Ja gucken wir uns das mal an.
Er hat sich Minecraft 2 gekauft.
Von EA Sports selbstverständlich.
Ich habe mir Minecraft 2 gekauft.
Skyrim 2.
Und FIFA 42.
Und all diese Spiele sind scheiße.
Hinter jeden 5 Blöcken beim neuen Minecraft Teil.
Seine Paywall.
Und all das wegen EA Sports.
Mein Sohn.
Hättest du bloß niemals diese Spiele vorbestellt.
Da ist wohl was dran.
Ey.
Der Ursprungstrailer war auch echt nice.
Also der einzige.
Also der einzige Zweig.
Von.
Wobei wahrscheinlich war es noch nicht mal da.
Okay der einzige Zweig von EA.
Der bei Battlefield 2042 vor Release.
Ganze Arbeit geleistet hat.
War die Marketing Abteilung.
Weil die haben den Shit.
Wirklich gut verkauft.
Als ich die Beta gespielt habe.
Oder diesen internal Test.
Oder wie auch immer sie es genannt haben.
Ich hatte schon ein bisschen meine Zweifel.
Gerade was die Wetterevents angeht.
Die wirken für mich von Anfang an so eingefügt.
Weil man sonst nichts hatte.
Und ein bisschen zu nervig vor allem.
Aber.
Im Nachhinein hat es sich bestätigt.
2042.
Leute das wird das beste Battlefield.
Was wir jemals gespielt haben.
EA sagt das neue Battlefield ist weit vor dem Zeit.
Ja das haben sie ja echt erzählt.
EA sagt die Updates für Battlefront 2 werden eingestellt.
Um an dem neuen Battlefield zu arbeiten.
EA sagt das neue Battlefield wird dominieren.
Merkt euch an solche Worte.
EA sagt vier Entwicklerstudios arbeiten ausschließlich an diesem Spiel.
Das merkt man auch.
Und vor allem merkt man auch dass die Fahrzeugphysik.
Total pepega ist in Battlefield 2042.
Trotz Need for Speed Entwicklern.
Looks amazing.
Ist das die möglicherweise größte Werbekampagne.
Auf all time.
Leute dieses Spiel wird der Call of Duty Killer.
Auf den wir Jahre gewartet haben.
Der Hype ist riesig.
Und schlussendlich der Trailer mit dem Rondezoo.
Dem legendärsten Battlefield Move aller Zeiten.
Man springt aus seinem Jet.
Zerstört ein anderes Flugzeug.
Und landet wieder an seinem eigenen Jet.
Das war schon cool gemacht.
EZEN! EZEN! EZEN!
EZEN! EZEN!
AU!
Also wenn ich so aus Flip Influence Leute immer sehe.
Ich hab immer den Eindruck.
Die haben das Video vorher schon mal gesehen.
Und reacten dann halt so drauf.
Wie sie denken das es den Leuten am besten gefällt.
Dystopische Setting.
Die größten Maps.
Auf all time. Tornados.
Explosion. Tornado Explosion.
Meinst du das ist gespielt?
Nein. Auf gar keinen Fall.
Also Soldaten.
Das wird der härteste Kampf unseres Lebens.
Wir haben jahrelang auf diesen Tag gewartet.
Let's fucking go.
Oh fuck das Spiel ist nicht mal ansatzweise fertig.
Warum bin ich so unglaublich schnell?
Das Schlauchboot kann an Wänden hochfahren.
Das fand ich geil. Das ist doof.
Dass sie das nicht beibehalten haben.
Ich fand das mega nice.
Dass du mit dem Schlauchboot die Wände hochfahren kannst.
Das ist der einzige Weg da überhaupt drauf zu kommen.
Also nein man konnte theoretisch die Treppe laufen.
Aber du hattest da nur zwei Ausgänge.
Also im Prinzip bist du da nicht hoch gekommen.
Mit dem Schlauchboot war die einzige Möglichkeit
die Base überhaupt zu erobern.
Ich bin jetzt kein Experte.
Aber ich glaube das geht im echten Leben nicht.
Leute laufen in der Luft. Das Schlauchboot kann fliegen.
Kollision ist ziemlich realistisch.
Ich fliege durch den Sand durch.
Server crashes. Fuck.
Ich neife die Luft. Warum werde ich durch die Luft geworfen?
Random Explosion.
Meiner Grafikkarte gehts gar nicht gut.
Der Panzer hat keine Gravitation.
Was macht eine Sehraube hier?
Was ist falsch mit seinem Gesicht? Was ist falsch mit dem Flugzeug?
Meine Waffen machen keinen Schaden.
Sehr empfindlicher Computer.
Ich glaube so wird mich keiner entdecken.
Epileptische Anfall.
Warum sterbe ich?
Warum ist mein Teamate eingefroren?
Meine Gegner verschwinden in der Wand.
Meine Gegner sind überkoppt.
Diese Sliden auf dem Boden.
Das gab es auch schon in ganz alten Battlefield-Teilen.
Da habe ich mich auch immer gefragt.
Was ist denn hier los?
Da ist einfach auf Grand Bazaar die Map geslided.
Ich kann mit meinem vollsten Patronen schießen.
Hallo Sohn. Bist du am Gewinnen?
Keine Ahnung. Es gibt nicht mal einen fucking Scoreboard in diesem Spiel.
So mein Legacy-Feature.
Muss man sich jetzt auch nicht beschweren.
Nun, wie man sich denken kann, waren sehr viele Leute sehr unglücklich über das Spiel.
Ein wenig.
Insofern ist es schon ein bisschen nach hinten losgegangen.
Wenn du die Leute so mega krass hypesst
und nichts davon erfüllst,
ist natürlich die Enttäuschung auch noch mal viel größer.
Letztendlich ist es egal.
Alle die Vorbestellten haben bezahlt. Easy Money, Easy Life.
Und überflutet mit schlechten Rezensionen.
Leute posten Kuchenrezepte.
Der klassische, ich kaufe lieber Winrar-Kommentar.
Und die einzigen positiven Kommentare sind darüber,
wie gut das Ding ist.
Und dann gibt es auch noch ein paar andere.
Und die einzigen positiven Kommentare sind darüber,
wie gut das Deinstallieren vom Spiel denn funktionieren würde.
Ich hätte mir auch Essen kaufen können.
Das am gleichen Tag erschienene Spiel Pepperwood
vernichtet Battlefield mit Vorsprung.
Und auch YouTube ist, naja, nicht amüsiert.
Die Leute finden das Spiel ein bisschen unausgearbeitet.
Und lassen das EA auch spüren.
Aber...
Wisst ihr was?
Ich habe eine Sache von Anfang an prediktet.
Max, das kann überhaupt nicht sein, weil...
Ich habe von Anfang an gesagt,
okay, die werden
in irgendeiner Art und Weise versuchen,
ein bisschen die Matches auszugleichen.
So was wie SBMM.
Vielleicht nicht so krass wie in Call of Duty,
weil es schwierig ist mit so vielen Spielern.
Und man im Zweifelsfall
aber halt versuchen möchte,
besser die Leute zu halten.
Das geht halt mit ausgeglichenen Spielen besser.
Und dementsprechend
war meine Schlussfolgerung daraus,
das können sie nur machen...
19 Milliarden
Bits Pongers.
Das können sie nur machen,
wenn es keinen
Serverbrowser gibt.
Beziehungsweise wenn es
Quick Match gibt,
was hauptsächlich benutzt wird.
Und alle haben gesagt, nein, Max,
das wird es in Battlefield nicht geben.
Das kann überhaupt nicht sein, weil Serverbrowser
ist eine Pflicht. Und ich war schon skeptisch,
dass man im Vorfeld nie,
obwohl sie es glaube ich irgendwann mal
sogar bestätigt haben, dass es den geben wird,
dass man im Vorfeld nie den Serverbrowser
gesehen hat. Sehr, sehr merkwürdig,
wie die das immer gezeigt haben.
Und dann war es soweit, Release, es gab
keinen Serverbrowser.
Es gab natürlich nach wie vor super krasse Fanboys,
die gesagt haben, Max, natürlich gibt es einen Serverbrowser,
es gibt doch jetzt Battlefield Portal.
Es ist aber ein kleiner Unterschied,
ob es irgendeinen dritten Spielmodus
gibt,
wo dann Leute Custom-Spielmodi
zusammenklicken, die teilweise
extrem mies gemacht sind, weil die Leute
der Meinung sind, ah, man braucht jetzt One Bullet,
Kills, All, Nosher, Cannons, Only,
oder so komische Dinge, was eh keiner
spielt. Und da kannst du die Server auswählen,
wo du teilweise noch nicht mal XP machen
konntest, teilweise nicht mal anlocken konntest,
oder eben ein
richtiger Serverbrowser
mit offiziellen Servern drin,
oder aber auch mietbaren Servern,
die dann auch wiederum
ordentliche Möglichkeiten haben,
weil das, was Portal heutzutage
bietet, ist weit
hinter dem zurück, also ich rede jetzt
nicht von Inhalte bauen, sondern von
Server betreiben, das ist
weit, weit, weit hinter dem zurück,
was zum Beispiel noch
auch bei uralt Games, die jetzt abgeschaltet werden,
wie Bad Company 2 möglich war.
In Bad Company 2
konntest du,
und in Battlefield 3 auch noch,
und in Battlefield 4 zum Teil auch noch,
konntest du Server Plugins
hinzufügen, und du
konntest zum Beispiel auf deinem Server
einstellen, dass du
nur maximal, keine Ahnung, du hast
24 vs 24
Rush eingestellt,
du konntest sagen, es darf maximal
2 oder 3 oder 4
oder wie auch immer, oder gar kein
feste Sniper Spots
pro Team geben.
Dann konntest du ein Plugin installieren,
und der hat das beschränkt, dass die Leute
Sniper auswählen können, was sehr gut
war, und auch gerade in Rush
zu viel besseren Runden geführt hat,
als manchmal auf Public Servern,
wo 60-70
Prozent, so auch der
Attacker, teilweise am Arsch
der Welt und nice Longshot
machen wollten. Aber das wollten
sie natürlich nicht mehr, das
wollten sie natürlich nicht mehr, weil es kann
doch nicht sein, dass ein Server Betreiber
entscheiden kann, wie die Leute spielen
sollen auf dem Server, und das würde dir dann vielleicht
Leute einschränken, die ihre
geile Sache im Battle Pass
unlockt haben, und dann spielen die
nicht mehr und sowas.
Wo wir wieder eigentlich beim ursprünglichen
Problem sind, dass Spiele heutzutage
nicht mehr für den besten Spielspaß,
für das beste Gameplay
oder für das beste Spiel, oder besser gesagt
für das, was eventuell die Entwickler am liebsten
selbst spielen wollen, entwickelt wird,
sondern für
Stonks.
Moment mal, wenn das Spiel von allen
verhasst wird, warum sind auf der Homepage
dann ausschließlich nahezu perfekte
Reviews? EA nimmt einfach Reviews
von irgendwelchen unbekannten Seiten, die
wahrscheinlich auch noch bezahlt worden sind, und vermarkten das Spiel
als Spiel des Jahres.
Attack of the Fanboy
4 von 5. Hobby Consolas
84.
Hobby Consolas.
Das bin ich gerade nicht aufgefallen,
Alter. Was Sie da
so ein Scheiß drauf stehen haben.
Hobby Consolas, wer hat es doch nicht gehört.
All diese Seiten sind zum Großteil
spanische und französische Klatschmagazine.
Diese Reviews sind überhaupt nichts
wert. Okay, außer IGN
mit einer 7, aber guckt euch bitte diese
Ratio an.
IGN, too much water.
Fucking
Farming Simulator hat mehr
aktive Spieler als...
Farming Simulator.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal was vermeintlich
lustiges. Wusstet ihr das?
Farming Simulator
eSports?
Wusstet ihr, dass es das
gibt? Farming
Simulator eSport?
Farming
Simulator League Season 2
Finals. Und
die flippen voll aus dabei.
Farming
Simulator
eSport?
Das ist
... da geht es ab.
Das ist ein beeindruckendes Start.
Als sie
über die Linie gehen.
Um die 42. Linie.
Das Team hat einen Grund, zu wechseln.
Halt es, halt es.
Halt es.
Das ist das, was wir hier machen.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass das wirklich nicht einfach ist.
Ich weiß halt bloß nicht ob.
Keine Ahnung.
Farming Simulator
eSport?
Wie ist es dazu überhaupt gekommen?
It's very clever.
You have to pick a bäiler,
that's next to a harvester.
Jump out of the tractor and run all the way over.
In an ideal world
the harvester is to the right of the bäiler.
Da gibt's auch irgendwie...
Was hab ich gesehen? Teams?
Teams von irgendwelchen... Also da haben da tatsächlich
irgendwelche Landwirtschaftsgeräte hergestellt.
Da haben da ein Farming Simulator, eSport Teams und sowas.
Ich muss ja sagen,
bevor wir das Video weiter gucken,
wo ich das alles sagen soll, wusstet ihr das
auf einem der letzten
Gamescom Besuche,
die ich...
wo ich gewesen bin?
Schon eine ganze Weile her.
Weiß nicht, wann das war.
Das ist ewig her.
Da konnte Montana Black noch rumlaufen
ohne Bodyguards.
Zumindest...
der Farming Simulator
Stand
war
eines der meist Besuchten.
Da war immer viel los.
Na gut, eines der meist Besuchten. Das ist krass.
Das war ein kleiner Stand, aber es war immer viel los.
Und wisst ihr warum?
Wisst ihr warum?
Weil
einzig und allein wegen
Buber.
Die hatten
auf ihrem Farming Simulator
stand, hatten sie halt das Game,
ein paar Monitore und sowas,
und hatten einen Traktor.
Einen polierten
Traktor stehen,
wo sich den ganzen Tag
zwei Mädels drauf rumgerollt, recht leicht
begleitete Mädels drauf rumgerollt haben.
Auf diesem Traktor.
Und du konntest dann da hingehen und mit den Fotos machen
und dich auch auf dem Traktor rumrollen,
wenn du wolltest.
Und das ist richtig gut angekommen anscheinend.
Deswegen war am Farming Simulator
stand immer was los.
Jetzt gucken wir das Video erstmal weiter.
Und das Spiel wird durch die negativen Reviews
auf das mittlerweile acht
meist gedisleichteste Spiel
auf Steam katapultiert.
Ja, zurecht.
Oh nein, hier kommt der Battlefield Release.
Was wird wohl mit der EA Aktie passieren?
Nein.
Der Preis des Spiels
fällt kurzzeitig auf 5.
Es gab ja irgendwie zwei Monate nach Release
oder so schon ein Free Weekend
und sowas.
Heißt also Battlefield 2042 oder 1 Kilo Tomaten,
die man weint auf das EA Gebäude werfen kann.
Und dann gibt es noch die Kommentare von
EA Mitarbeitern, wie zum Beispiel
alle Fans sind angepisst Leute, eure Erwartungen
sind brutal.
Der Typ war eh geil.
Ich glaube bis heute,
dass der das einfach nur
blöd formuliert hat.
Ich glaube, der hat das einfach nur blöd formuliert.
Er hat ja im Prinzip Recht.
Es kann nicht sein,
dass durch kack
und so unfähige
Entscheidungen, die im Vorfeld getroffen wurden,
wo die Entwickler selbst vielleicht gar nichts
für können, sie das jetzt ausbauen sollen,
indem sie über Weihnachten überarbeiten
müssen und sowas. Da würde ich ihm ja Recht geben.
Wobei ich immer noch denke,
dass der Fail von Battlefield 2042
nicht nur die Schuld
von EA Management ist, sondern
DICE es auch maßgeblich
mit verkackt hat. Ich meine, die haben den Kram entwickelt.
Natürlich unter gewissen Vorgaben.
Aber ich glaube, das war ein
Multilevel-Fail-Versagen,
das Battlefield 2042
so geworden ist.
Und da haben bestimmt auch
Leute zu beigetragen, wo man jetzt erstmal
vielleicht nicht so dran denkt.
Trotzdem, im Prinzip würde ich ihm Recht geben.
Es kann nicht sein, dass es dann der
einfache Entwickler ausbauen muss,
selbst wenn sie in der Entwicklung Sachen verkackt haben,
indem er über Weihnachten
und sowas arbeiten muss. Aber
es war schlecht
formuliert zu einer schlechten
Zeit, das rauszuhauen
auf Twitter.
Wobei man sagen muss, dass
Battlefield und Marketing ja eh schon nicht
gut funktioniert haben. Spätestens
seit Battlefield 1 erinnert sich noch einer
an den Herrn, wie hieß er?
Söderlund, glaube ich, hieß er.
Ich glaube, das war
der. Oder irgendeiner.
Ich glaube, Söderlund hieß er.
Der gesagt hat,
wir sind richtig und ihr seid
falsch und wenn es euch nicht gefällt, dann kauft
Battlefield 5. Battlefield 5 war es nicht,
Battlefield 1. Und wenn es euch nicht
gefällt, dann kauft euch einfach nicht.
Und was ist passiert?
Die Leute haben
sich nicht gekauft. Tja.
Vielleicht sollte man nicht ganz so
selbstsicher
und reißerisch
darüber reden.
Oder der Release von Halo Infinite
in der gleichen Woche. Ja, bla bla bla bla.
Unser Spiel floppt. Ja, und die
Pizza ist schuld, dass ich fett bin. Und das
Brecheisen ist schuld, dass ich in dein Haus einbreche.
Böser CEO, böser CEO.
Oh, und du hast die 120 Euro
Ultimate Edition gekauft mit dem Artbook
und dem Soundtrack vom Spiel. Du kriegst eine
PDF. Der Soundtrack. Wait a minute.
Das Spiel. Passt mal auf.
Passt mal auf, Leute.
Der Soundtrack.
Wenn ihr mal absolut
Ear Cancer bekommen wollt,
dann hört euch den Battlefield
2042 Soundtrack an.
Man darf abgesehen, dass er nur 42 Minuten ist,
aber seriously.
Official.
Official Soundtrack.
Jetzt mein ernsthaft.
Es wird noch schlimmer gleich.
Es wird gleich noch schlimmer.
What the fuck.
Alter.
Was zum Teufel soll das sein?
Und das ist auch eines der besseren Teile.
Das ist auch eines der besseren Teile, weil man
irgendwie noch ansatzweise
mit dem Soundtrack
und dem Soundtrack
irgendwie noch ansatzweise
das Battlefield Main Theme
raushören kann, wenn man sich
anstrengt.
Aber ernsthaft, was ist das?
Das hört sich nach kaputter
Soundkarte an. Genau.
Ich quäle euch auch nicht länger.
Die anderen Dinger sind noch schlimmer.
Oder nicht vorhanden.
Was zum?
Was ist das?
Also,
also, nee, nee.
Seriously.
In diesem Video
nur ganz kurz.
Ernsthaft. Nee, also, was?
Einfach nur verkackt.
Übrigens.
Mein Hintergrund finde ich schöner.
In meiner Form.
Das ist nicht
Pepo Z durchs Fenster, sondern
White Pepo Happy am Windows XP Hügel.
Battlefield Bad Company 2
Soundtrack immer noch besser.
Das stimmt, aber wisst ihr, was ich die beste
Battlefield, wo wir gerade dabei sind,
die beste Battlefield Theme
Iteration
Äh.
Finde.
Das da.
Das ist das Intro, wo der
Hubschrauber kommt. Und jetzt gleich
den Part.
Die hat noch ein richtiges
Orchester, Mann.
Das geht als
Soundtrack durch, oder?
Also, das kann man, das ist
wenigstens ein ordentlicher Soundtrack.
Nicht dieses Weird Champ Shit von
Battlefield 2042.
Okay, wo sind wir? Stehen geblieben.
Eine PDF-Datei und ein paar
MP3-Dateien zugesendet.
Eine PDF-Datei, die es bereits umsonst
im Internet zu finden gibt.
Und den Soundtrack, den man umsonst auf
YouTube hören kann. Das Spiel kommt
außerdem mit dem Portal-Modus, bei dem man
Maps aus verschiedenen Zeitepochen mit
verschiedenen Waffen und Fahrzeugen spielen kann.
Der wurde nach Release sofort offline
genommen, weil Leute in den Lobbys ihre
XP.
Leute, ohne Scheiß, das habe ich auch
vor Release gesagt.
Könnt ihr euch noch gerade erinnern, ich habe
im Tube gesagt, wie wollen sie das eigentlich
machen, dass die Leute das nicht abusen
mit XP-Farben und
Unlocks-Farben und so was.
Und was kommt raus?
Was passiert, nachdem das Game
rausgekommen ist? Die Leute farben XP und
Unlocks drinne.
Alter.
Wobei ich das noch nicht mal schlimm finde, ehrlich gesagt.
Weil, es war eh Pains Champ.
Am Anfang.
Hey, wenn das Spiel absolut scheiße ist und der andere
Modus eh nicht geht, kann ich ja wenigstens
die Kampagne spielen.
Hazard Zone kannst du spielen, was
mittlerweile eingestellt wurde.
Mein Sohn, es gibt keine
Kampagne, du Vollidiot.
EA hat sich dazu entschieden, anstatt
an einem Story-Modus zu arbeiten, alle
Kapazitäten in den Multiplayer-Modus
zu stecken. Es gibt kein Scoreboard.
Wozu dann überhaupt die groß
angekündigte Storyline? Wegen der tiefen
Charakterentwicklung etwa? Battlefield
im Jahr 2042.
Nach der größten Krise der Menschheitsgeschichte
Ressourcenmangelherrschaft der Welt.
Alle deine Freunde sind tot. Oh, Harambe.
Dick's out.
Zwei Wochen später brachte EA dann
passend zum Setting eine Santa Claus
Skin raus.
Und den Cowboy.
Und den Cowboy-Skin. Die kamen beide nicht gut an.
Der laut Medien bereits vorher in einer
internen Feedback-Session niedergestimmt
wurde, aber dann einfach trotzdem hinzugefügt
wurde. Ja, weil man sonst keinen anderen Content
hatte. Werbung in einem Spiel,
wofür man bereits 70 Euro gezahlt
hat. Gefällt euch das? EA
Sportsfuck.
Das Reddit-Forum
zu Battlefield wird daraufhin so unglaublich
toxisch, dass Reddit überlegt, das komplett
sperren zu lassen. Bringt das Scoreboard zurück
oder dieser Pinguin wird verschossen?
Läustiger Bengt da ist. Nun bringt bitte das
echte Spiel raus. Eine Petition wird gestartet,
damit Leute das Spiel zurückgeben können.
Und EA denkt sich,
nein. Hey, aber ich habe dafür
80 Euro bezahlt. Sag mal, was meint ihr?
Wie lang schneidet man an so einem Video?
16 Minuten in diesem Tempo
mit dem Content,
mit den Schnitten,
mit dem, was man an Material braucht. Da bist du doch
bestimmt zwei, drei Wochen beschäftigt.
Also, was genau ist passiert?
EA gab 2020 dem Entwicklerstudio
die Aufgabe,
kopiert einfach das, was beliebt ist.
Das Studio hat daraufhin monatelang an einem
Battlefield 2042
Battle Royale gearbeitet.
Und EA kam dann ein paar Monate später
und dachte sich,
und so wurde alles über den Haufen geworfen.
Außerdem wurde eine Engine benutzt, mit der das
Entwicklerteam noch nicht vertraut war.
Dann hat sich rausgestellt, dass nach dem sehr
kontroversen Launch von Battlefield 5
Was heißt nicht vertraut war?
DICE hat Frostbite erfunden.
Das Problem ist nur, dass sie fast alle
Leute, die sich damit ausgekannt haben,
verloren haben über die letzten Jahre.
Was bestimmt
maßgeblich auch
an den letzten Battlefield
Teilenberg, wie das gelaufen ist.
Eine Vielzahl an Elite-Entwicklern
sich dazu entschieden, wegen der schlechten Firmenpolitik
von EA zu kündigen.
Heißt so viel wie,
die vier Entwicklerteams waren eigentlich nur ein paar
zusammengewürfelte und unerfahrene Mitarbeiter.
Und als man merkte, man ist nicht mal
ansatzweise im Zeitplan, hat man sich dazu entschieden,
ganze Features und Funktionen...
Ja, und man hat sich dazu entschieden,
und man hat sich dazu entschieden zu sagen,
man ist way ahead of schedule,
obwohl man eigentlich
das Gegenteil ist.
Es gibt keinen Voice Chat.
Die ganze Animation wurde einfach entfernt.
Man kann nicht tauchen in diesem Spiel.
Okay, das ist nicht ganz wahr. Man muss nur
lange genug aggressiv auf das Wasser einstechen.
Man hinterlässt nirgendswo Fußabdrücke,
außer auf steinhartem Beton.
Die Maps sind so unfassbar groß und leer,
dass man irgendwo im Nirgendwo
spawnet und entweder sofort stirbt
oder stundenlang laufen muss. Das Ganze fiel
so vielen Spielern auf, dass Leute daraufhin anfingen,
das Subreddit mit lustigen Map-Ideen zu klugen.
In anderen Battlefield-Teilen fallen einfach mal
ganze Gebäude und Map-Teile auf dich drauf.
Wow, man sprengt mit einer Granate,
ein Truck hoch und er fliegt durch die Luft.
Funktioniert nicht. Funktioniert nicht.
Funktioniert nicht.
Die Liste geht noch etwas länger,
aber ich glaube, ihr versteht das Prinzip.
Alles, was am Ende übrig blieb,
war ein halbfertiges, mittelmäßiges Spiel.
Über die nächsten Monate sollten anschließend
die Patches kommen, um das Spiel wieder zu flicken.
Wie großzügig von EA.
Nach vier Monaten gab es endlich
ein Scoreboard. Und noch ein paar Patches
später...
Ja, du kannst bis heute nicht gescheit die
Squats wechseln.
Also...
Es gibt ja irgendwie die Möglichkeit Squat
Selection, aber da geht auch nicht alles.
Also es ist immer noch ziemlich
für den Arsch.
Willkommen in der Zukunft.
Und heute ist das Spiel ganz okay.
Doch sind wir mal ehrlich. Wo liegt der Sinn darin,
wenn man ein halbfertiges Spiel veröffentlicht,
nur um es monatelang danach fertig
patchen zu müssen, um Schadensbegrenzung zu
betreiben oder um noch irgendwie den eigenen
Ruf zu retten. Und vor ein paar Tagen gab es sogar
die ersten Hinweise darauf, dass das Spiel noch
ein Jahr länger Support bekommt, damit es
endlich auch mal fertig wird. Nun,
wenigstens wurde hier einmal die richtige Entscheidung
getroffen. Doch das Spiel und der Release
war sicher kein Einzelfall.
2017. Mass Effect an
Drummilder. Für dieses Spiel wurde als der
revolutionäre Spiel... Mittlerweile ist das eigentlich
fast bei vielen großen
AAA Releases Standard,
dass die Games in
rohem Zustand mit wenig Content
kommen, um sie dann mit der Zeit weiter
zu entwickeln. Das Problem ist nur,
dass ganz
viele Games mit großen
Service-Game-Ambitionen
starten und dann irgendwie
ein halbes Jahr oder eineinhalb Jahre später
oder so dichtgemacht werden, weil ja spielt ja
keiner. Das hat
keiner was von gehabt.
Epische Bosskämpfe, riesige Welten
zum Erkunden. Das sieht halt schon geil aus.
Das sieht echt krass gut aus.
Norm viele Gamer waren hyped auf
diesen Titel.
Und 40 Millionen Dollar und
fünf Jahre Entwicklung später wurde es
öffentlich.
Ja, das war auch übelst kaputt.
Die Waffe wird halt schon
gehalten. T-Cosing im All. Alien
Schlangmenschen. Und diese
Gesichtsanimation scheint sehr gut ausgearbeitet.
Sehr realistische Kampfanimation.
Okay, Leute, das Spiel ist doch
wow, das ist ziemlich realistisch.
Ey, Leute, bitte lasst mich auf.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern,
wo die NPCs gespawnt sind, als ich nicht mehr
bewegen konnte.
Warum geht mein Auto nicht?
What the fuck is this shit?
Oh nein, wir
werden sterben. Guckt euch unsere
angst erfüllten Gesichter an. Oh nein.
Also, Leute, willkommen zu meinem
Let's Plane. Das Spiel war
ein absoluter Flop. Die Reviews waren
sehr lustig zu lesen. Der Tag an dem
Mass Effect. Tod!
Und die Rechtfertigung vom EA-Sprecher
war danach. Der Release von
Zelda Breath of the Wild im gleichen
Monat sei schuldengelesen, dass unser Spiel
floppt.
Komm, wir bringen ein Spiel
raus.
Scheiß Zelda. Oder
Mass Effect Andromeda ist gescheitert, weil es
nicht genug Diversität im Spiel gab.
Okay, wir brauchen blaue Aliens, rote
Aliens, umgedrehte Aliens.
Das ist aber so ein Phänomen.
Das habe ich auch schon bei meinem alten
Arbeitgeber und bei Managern gemerkt.
Die
Selbstreflektion
ist teilweise nicht ganz
da. So nach dem Motto
Oh, wir haben eine scheiß Entscheidung getroffen.
Kann ja durchaus sein, dass die Entscheidung
im damaligen Moment sinnvoll aussah.
Aber man weiß jetzt nach einem Jahr,
wir haben eine scheiß Entscheidung getroffen.
Aber ohne dann zu sagen, okay,
es war damals
nach den gegebenen Sachen
richtig sich so zu entscheiden, aber jetzt
haben wir draus gelernt, jetzt müssen wir es besser, also zumindest
irgendwie zuzugeben im
Rückblick, dass es sich nicht so entwickelt hat
wie behofft.
Das ist
nicht möglich anscheinend.
Oh, lass es mal nicht Twitter sehen.
Da ist Twitter schon wieder hart getriggert jetzt.
Oh.
Game not included.
In der Collector's Edition,
seriously. Was noch viel
nicer war, ist
erinnert sich noch einer
bei Fallout dran.
An diese Sache
mit der Cola.
Das war auch so
ein Fail in der Richtung.
Collector's Edition Cola und
dann gab es erst keine und dann sollte es
noch irgendwie einen Rucksack geben und dann gab es auch
keinen Rucksack und in irgendeinem Fall gab es
so eine billige China-Chinesen-Cola für
zwei Euro,
die noch nicht mal zusammengepasst hat.
Jetzt steht es für das Spiel endgültig ein.
Star Wars Battlefront II.
Jahrelanger Hype für den
Nachfolger der berüchtigten Battlefront-Reihe.
Und da ist er endlich.
Der Trailer.
Kämpfen in epischen Schlachten mit der Lieblingscharakter
aus Star Wars. EA bringt es raus
und hey, das Game funktioniert ja tatsächlich.
Keine Bugs.
Aber schöne Unlocking.
Um Darth Vader und Luke Skywalker
freizuschalten. Wie bitte?
Ich muss sechs volle Monate 24-7
grinden, um überhaupt alle
Inhalte in Battlefront II freizuschalten.
Oder ich bezahle einfach sehr viel Geld.
Alle Upgrades sind ausschließlich
in Lootboxen zu finden.
Das wurde auch nur geändert,
weil
genau, das Pay2Win hat
diesmal ein wirklich gutes Game
versaut.
Weil
mal, Sekunde.
Ich glaube, ich muss was tippen.
Fuck, was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Pay2Win hat eigentlich ein gutes Game versaut.
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Aber, was ich sonst noch dazu sagen kann.
Da sieht man wieder,
wobei Battlefront II
teilweise tatsächlich ganz
beliebt war, auch durch die Star Wars Filme.
Disney hat gesagt,
so geht das nicht,
weil es war für sie zu schlechte Publicity.
Letztendlich, als wäre Disney
irgendwas, die was gegen Geld hätten.
Das ist ja auch so ein Laden,
die auch alles machen, was Kohle bringt.
Zumindest war es einfach
zu schlechtes Marketing für die.
Battlefront II ist ein Paradebeispiel
dafür.
Als Argument
den ganzen Leuten, die immer behaupten,
reine Cosmetics machen ja nichts.
Oder noch besser,
solange man es auch durch Spielen anlocken kann,
ist doch okay.
Das hat man gesehen, dass es in Battlefront II eben nicht so ist.
In dem Fall waren es nicht reine Cosmetics,
weil es waren Helden,
die man anlocken kann und
ändert ja auch das Gameplay.
Aber so eine grundlegende Sache ändert sich,
sobald der Fokus von,
man möchte dem Spieler irgendwas bieten in Game zu,
man möchte
viele Transactions haben,
sobald sich der Fokus ändert.
Nämlich, das hat
unwiederbringlich,
wenn du das
als Ziel nimmst, du kannst es nicht ändern,
ist, dass es
muss Auswirkungen darauf haben,
wie du dein Game gestaltest.
Dann ist es nicht so, dass du sagst, hey, gut,
du machst jetzt 50 Headshots mit der Waffe,
dann kriegst du das in Gold. Easy.
Ist eine gute Challenge,
kriegt ein guter Spieler auch gut hin,
aber es ist jetzt nichts,
wo du jetzt sagen würdest, hey,
da musst du drei Monate am Stück 24-7
grinden, das ist okay,
aber sobald du sagst, hey,
man möchte das ja
verkaufen, dann
musst du dein Spiel ändern. Dann werden
so Dinge wie, die du früher als netten
Bonus für eben besonders
gute oder besonders
engagierte Spieler, die da viel Zeit reinstecken,
hattest, auf einmal
so umgestrickt, dass es nicht
mehr ist, du kannst es anlocken, wenn du dir nur Mühe gibst,
sondern du sollst
es eigentlich gar nicht anlocken können,
damit du dir es vielleicht kaufst, weil wenn du
siehst, okay, du hast zwar Progress, aber der
Progress ist so lahm, aber du kannst
den Progress jetzt mit 10 Euro
auffüllen, dann denkst du, okay,
ich hab da jetzt schon 80 Stunden reingesteckt,
wenn ich jetzt noch 10 Euro ausgebe,
dann erspare ich mir weitere
300 Stunden grinden und bekomme
quasi die 80 Stunden wieder und so.
Da sind ja immer so psychologische Tricks dahinter.
Das muss Auswirkungen auf das
Game haben.
Das heißt, auch reines
Kosmetik
und reines
Spielzeit
Erkaufen, quasi,
hat immer Auswirkungen
auf das Game und deswegen
bin ich mittlerweile auch sehr skeptisch, wenn
Games ankommen mit
wir kosten zwar 80 Euro,
aber haben
direkt
Transactions am Start.
Ich verstehe es
zum Teil, ja,
wenn man Spiele
betreiben möchte, über
3-4 Jahre oder länger,
wenn man so Games hat wie
vielleicht in Zukunft Diablo oder
Path of Exile oder Destiny oder sowas.
Die müssen ja auch schon gucken,
wie die Kohle
reinkommt.
Man muss genau drauf schauen,
wie die das machen. Ich persönlich denke, dass Path of Exile
ein richtig gutes Monetarisierungsmodell
hat.
Du musst erstmal nichts kaufen.
Es gibt ein paar
sehr angenehme Sachen, wie zum
Beispiel erweiterte
Kistenplätze und sowas.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass Path of Exile
standardmäßig auch gar nichts kostet.
Es ist nicht 80 Euro Vollpreisspiel,
wo du dann zusätzlich noch Zeug
kaufen sollst, sondern es ist ein
kostenloses Spiel.
Und du musst
auch für deinen ersten Character, du musst
nicht wirklich was kaufen.
Irgendwann, wenn du im Endgame bist und es dir
immer noch Spaß macht, nachdem du da schon 50-60
Stunden reingesteckt hast, dann denkst du dir
irgendwann, ok, ein bisschen mehr Inventar-Space,
gerade wenn ich einen zweiten Character machen will
und so. Aber in Path of Exile
war das einzige Game bisher,
was ich so free to play gespielt habe,
wo ich persönlich das
Verlangen
verspürt habe,
den Hersteller zu unterstützen,
indem ich was kaufe.
Nicht so sehr, ich wurde jetzt einfach
lang genug gegängelt,
bis ich sage, ich kauf was, sondern
ich hab von mir aus gesagt, ich kauf mir was
und ich kauf mir auch sinnloses Zeug,
wo ich beispielsweise überhaupt nichts von habe.
Ich hab mir zum Beispiel ein
Armour Set gekauft und irgendwie ein paar
Hideout-Skins. Total sinnlos,
braucht kein Mensch, aber ich hab's mir tatsächlich
mit dem Hintergrund gekauft,
weil ich mir dachte, hey,
ich hab das jetzt 300 Stunden oder so
gespielt,
irgendwie würde ich dir ganz gerne mal 10 Euro geben.
Gut, wahrscheinlich
war es am Ende auch ein bisschen mehr.
Letztendlich war das wirklich das einzige Spiel,
wo das bei mir gezogen hat, weil es ein gutes Game
ist. Und kein Game,
wo du merkst, es versucht dich an jeder Ecke
zu debaten, mit
irgendwelchen Transactions. Es macht
auch keinen Unterschied, also Path of Exile
macht auch keinen Unterschied, ob du ein
reiner Free-to-Play-Account bist
oder ein Account, der schon Sachen
für Microtransationen... Also es gibt
keine Drop-Boosts,
also du kannst hier keine Spielzeit erkaufen
in dem Sinn. Und das ist
finde ich auch ein recht faires
Free-to-Play-Modell.
Vollkommen in Ordnung und es läuft ja auch.
Man sieht das ja, die gibt es ja schon
lang genug und läuft auch ganz gut.
Was macht eigentlich Path of Exile 2?
Sollte das nicht auch irgendwann mal erscheinen?
Naja...
Und es muss, wie gesagt, das Einzige,
was ich sagen will, es muss, solche Entscheidungen
müssen Auswirkungen aufs Gameplay haben und
Battlefront 2 ist das beste Beispiel dafür.
Haha, geil!
Das erinnert mich an diesen Vogel,
der immer auf die Tastatur gehauen hat.
Geil! Da sieht man mal,
was für unerwartete Auswirkungen
sowas haben kann. Das ist ja geil, das habe ich überhaupt
nicht mitgekriegt.
Geil!
Okay, sehr witzig EA, nun gib mir bitte
mein Geld zurück. Wurde etwa der
Refund-Button entfernt?
Es gibt gar keinen
Refund-Button, du Vollidiot!
Wie man sich vorstellen kann, ist Reddit
auf die Barrikaden gegangen und der
EA Community Reddit-Account wurde so oft
druntergevoted, dass er nicht mal mehr genug
Reddit-Kammer hatte, um im Subreddit
Fragen zu beantworten.
Später in einer Anhörung bezüglich
Lootboxen und Glücksspiel sagte die EA
Vizepräsidentin dann, das wären
keine Lootboxen, das sind Überraschungs-
Mechanics.
Da kommt das her.
Die muss doch selbst lachen, wenn sie das sagt, oder?
Die hat doch eben selbst gelacht,
als sie das gesagt hat, oder?
Guckt ihr euch mal an!
Die muss doch selbst lachen!
Alter, die muss doch selbst lachen bei, wenn sie das sagt.
Das ist kein Überraschungsangebot, das Fleisch ist nicht roh,
es ist einfach nur nicht gebraten.
Und aua, das ist kein Banküberfall, das ist Überraschungskommunismus
und jetzt alle auf den Boden.
Und Lootboxen zu öffnen sei das gleiche,
wie wenn man ein Schoko-Überraschungsei auspackt.
Lootboxen wurden daraufhin in Belgien gebannt
und der Pay2win Aspekt wurde ein Jahr
später aus dem Spiel entfernt, nachdem
EA durch die ganze Sache bereits einen Haufen Kohle
gemacht hat. Und letztendlich wurde der Support
für das Spiel eingestellt.
Und das Game wanderte auf den Friedhof
der anderen ausgeschlachterten Spiele.
Übrigens damals eingestellt mit der Begründung
an Battlefield 2. Und jetzt, und jetzt, und jetzt
kommt auch Bad Company
1 und 2 dabei.
Ja gut, Anthem.
Das sieht so gut aus, es wird auf keinen Fall
scheitern.
Bugs, Bugs, Bugs, Connection-Probleme, Bugs
und noch mehr Bugs. Die Level-1-Waffe
ist stärker als alle legendären Waffen
im Spiel. Die Loading-Screens brauchen
zusammengerechnet länger als die eigentliche
Mission. Und das hier ist die Level-1-Rüstung.
Und das ist die legendärste Rüstung im Spiel.
Ah, logisch.
Sieht besser aus. Töte alle Gegner
diesen Bereich. Töte alle Gegner bis der Sender
aktiviert ist. Töte alle Gegner bis du wieder
einen neuen Bug bekommst. Das Problem bei der Anthem-Entwicklung,
das hat man im Nachhinein rausbekommen, war,
dass als erstes ein cooler Trailer
erstellt werden sollte, bevor ein
Game erstellt wurde.
So dachte ich mir auch, okay, wir haben jetzt hier was cooles.
Aber fuck, wie bauen wir da ein Game drum herum?
Ah, Dragon Age 1
war schon ein nice Game.
Da kann man, man könnte fast sagen,
so, so,
Dragon Age 1 und
vielleicht noch so
die ersten zwei Mass Effect,
vielleicht auch die, die, die erste Mass Effect
Trilogie. Danach war es das
mit Bioware, aber
ich will nicht sagen, dass das letzte,
was war das?
Inquisition war, glaube ich, das letzte
Dragon Age.
Will nicht sagen, dass das super schlecht ist.
Aber so,
so das große
Begeisterung ist da nicht mehr
übergesprungen.
F
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Es klingt vielleicht ein bisschen so.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich Bioshock entwickelt habe,
entwickelt, aber es war nicht Bioware.
Es war
Bioshock
Developer, weiß gar nicht, wer das gewesen ist.
Irrational
Games oder so was?
2K?
Okay, wüsste ich jetzt
Irrational Games, ja genau.
Also es ist, wie gesagt, es klingt
vielleicht so aus, weil es war nicht Bioware.
Übrigens, es gibt ja
Leute, die denken Warcraft, äh, nicht Warcraft 3,
Far Cry 3,
die hätten sich, die hätten sich das ausgedacht,
was Warstar sagt. Wisst ihr, von wem das
ursprünglich kommt? Die
Definition of Insanity?
Einstein, ja, richtig.
Also ich dachte zu, ich dachte auch
Einstein.
Back!
Da fehlen noch einige!
Ja!
Da erinnere ich mich noch dran,
das hatte so viele Probleme, hat er nicht
sogar Gronkh damals
raged und sein Let's Play eingestellt?
Ja, höre das Video!
Pogu!
Äh,
was man daran sieht, ist, dass auch solche
Fails immer eine gewisse Chance
bieten für andere Entwickler,
eben das, was verkackt wurde, was aber
ja offensichtlich, ja
seine, seine, seine
User findet,
seine Spieler findet,
da Kapital draus zu schlagen und das ist auch ganz
gut so.
Und ich glaube City Skylines wird jetzt
ja schon irgendwie das fünfte Jahr in Folge
supportet und geht immer noch gut.
Du hast deine 5k
ausgegeben?
Nice.
Äh, um mich daran zu erinnern,
dass ich was trinken muss.
Ach, eine Umfrage vorgeschlagen!
Größter EA Fail!
Okay, das können wir tatsächlich machen, das ist eine
gute, da müssen wir aber erstmal gucken, da gab's
jede Menge,
da gibt's
jede Menge Fails,
was war der größte, okay.
EA Games,
wie soll man da eine gescheite Umfrage machen?
Ich weiß doch gar nicht, was EA
alles für Games in den letzten Jahren rausgebracht hat,
das waren ganz schön viele, ja.
Also, natürlich ist das präsenteste
im Kopf, Battlefield,
das letzte.
Frag JetGP,
das ist eine gute Idee, das kann man
tatsächlich, das machen wir jetzt, wir fragen
JetGPT.
Wobei, JetGPT kennt sich nur bis
2021 aus.
Das
kriegen wir überhaupt nicht zusammen.
Man kann kein,
ich wüsste nicht, wie wir die Umfrage machen sollen.
Weil, man
kann ja keine Freitecks-Umfrage machen.
Trinken.
Ich frag mal JetGPT.
Wir fragen mal, was
Hallo?
Einloggen?
Da muss ich euch aber kurz ausmachen,
weil Leak, Leak
und so, von Passwort,
eventuell, man weiß ja nie,
Open,
AI, Chat,
Login.
Ich weiß, mein Passwort mittlerweile
zum Glück auswendig.
Oh.
Ich glaub, JetGPT ist gerade
down. Nö, geht.
Was auch immer.
Ich hab schon was getrunken.
Okay. Aber ich bau euch mal
wieder an. So, also, was, was
fragen wir?
Was waren die
größten, soll ich Flops oder
Fails? Was
war die größten
Gaming-Fails
von EA in den
letzten Jahren?
Auf geht's.
Kritische Ereignisse. Battlefront,
Lootboxen, Anthem.
Okay, JetGPT kriegst Mass Effect Andromeda.
SimCity Online.
Visceral Games wurde geschlossen.
Und mehr.
Die Ultimate Team Microsoft
Transactions.
Okay, da sagt mir gar nichts.
Battlefield V
und Controversen.
Stimmt!
Ja, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Die haben ja auch
das neue Command & Conquer eingestellt,
was eigentlich im ursprünglichen
Reveal-Trailer ganz okay ausgesehen hat.
Aber da muss man schon sagen, also
Battlefront 2, Lootboxen,
Anthem, Mass Effect
und Battlefield 2042.
Das war schon in den letzten Jahren so
eines der, okay, da können wir tatsächlich mal eine Umfrage
machen, was ihr denkt.
Machen wir mal größter
EA-Fail der
letzten Jahre.
Was soll ich noch reinnehmen? Also ich mach jetzt
Battlefront 2, Lootboxen.
Battlefield 2042.
Anthem.
SimCity.
Eins, eins können wir noch. Eins geht noch.
Es gehen nur fünf Sachen.
Man könnte noch, man könnte noch
Battlefield V tatsächlich mit reinnehmen.
Mit ihrem, ja, wir
wissen, wie die Geschichte war und sowas.
Okay, das reicht. Machen wir die vier
Sachen. Machen wir die vier Sachen rein.
In der ganzen FIFA-Geschichte und so bin ich nicht
drinne, keine Ahnung.
Also ich warte mal, bis das
durch ist und dann sage ich, sage ich
mein persönliches Ranking dafür.
Kein Doppel abstimmen.
Nee, das wird es ja, wenn ich
doppelt abstimmen lassen würde,
dann würde alles nur mit 33%
rauskommen.
Äh, 25%.
Das wäre ein bisschen
20%.
Wir haben ja vier.
Okay, Anthem.
Ja, Leute, ich muss sagen,
das ist fast auch so meine
persönliche, meine
persönliche Einschätzung. Also ich würde sagen,
Anthem war eines der größten
Fails der EA-Geschichte.
Gefolgt für mich persönlich
durch von Battlefield 2042.
Natürlich hat mich persönlich Battlefield 2042
mehr betroffen als Anthem, aber insgesamt
würde ich sagen, war Anthem schon
der größere Fail.
Bei mir käme auf dem dritten Platz SimCity
nicht 2020, weil
ich mochte früher SimCity als Reihe,
aber das habe ich mir nicht
gegeben. Und Battlefront 2
ging ein bisschen an mir vorbei, weil ich kein großer
Star-Wars-Fan bin.
Ja.
Letztendlich ist es nur eine Frage der Zeit,
bis der nächste große EA-Fail
um die Ecke kommt.
Ich bin nicht lange auf sich warten lassen.
So, was können wir uns jetzt als Nächstes
angucken? Das haben wir hier.
Das kann das iPhone 15 Pro.
Okay, ich rate
mal, was sie machen.
Wobei weiß man überhaupt
schon, was es geben
wird?
Oder ist das wieder so ein
Spekulationsding?
Könnt ihr euch auch daran erinnern?
Ist ja ein paar Mal passiert.
Nach dem Motto iPhone in der Kneipe
vergessen, Leaks sind raus.
Also es wird wahrscheinlich wieder
irgendwelche Änderungen an der Kamera geben,
weil Kamera
immer ein bisschen dran rumgedoktert wird.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich wieder ein bisschen
neue Farben.
Und ein paar Sachen,
wo es sich wahrscheinlich nicht wirklich
lohnt. Gucken wir mal.
Interessiert mich insofern tatsächlich,
weil ich habe mir erst vor kurzer Zeit einen
14er gekauft.
Und USB-C. Das wird
safe passieren.
Und jetzt mal alle aktuellen Gerüchte zusammen.
Es wird auch dieses Jahr wieder 4 iPhones geben.
Die günstigeren Modelle,
das 15 Plus
und das 15 Pro
und 15 Pro Max.
Oder wie viel kostet
denn aktuell
wie viel kostet denn aktuell ein
iPhone 14?
Ja, Geld.
Ach.
Moment, ich habe mich
vertan. 600 Euro.
600 Euro. In den
Sphären spielt Apple gar nicht.
1000 natürlich.
Das normale 14er.
Ja.
Dann ist Preis-Leistung
technisch das SE
ja tatsächlich noch das Beste.
Also ich habe aktuell
das hier.
Das hier.
Das 14er Max
ist mir zu groß.
Und
warum, warum habe ich das Pro
genommen? Ich weiß gar nicht.
Lass mal den Unterschied angucken.
Ja, Dynamic Islands ist so ein Ding.
Das hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Dynamic Islands ist so ein Ding.
Das hätte ich wirklich nicht gebraucht. Da hat man jetzt oben
hier in dieser Aussparung
hat man jetzt so ein Mini-Display noch drinne.
Das hätte ich nicht wirklich gebraucht.
Welches hast du für die Arbeit bekommen? Ich glaube
ein 12er.
Ich glaube das ist ein iPhone 12.
Always On, das war das erste was ich
ausgeschaltet habe.
Pro Motion
Technologie weiß ich gar nicht was es ist.
Die Kamera ist wirklich sehr nice.
Optische Zoom Optionen.
Ich glaube ich habe es hauptsächlich gekauft
weil es die neueste CPU
ist. Und 120
Hertz. Hatte es nicht auch 120
Hertz? Stand da
nicht was? Irgendwie normalerweise.
Ich glaube das war nämlich der Grund warum ich gedacht
habe, oh nice, mehr FPS.
Ist es nicht das erste
was auch 120 Hertz hat?
120 Hertz.
Ach das ist Pro Motion
ist 120 Hertz. Ja für
Leute wie mich müssten so 120 Hertz schreiben.
Das war glaube ich der hauptsächliche
Grund warum ich gesagt habe, auf gib ihm 120
Hertz Poggers.
Man merkt
es nicht wirklich.
Vielleicht ist es auch so
ein Ding, dass man den Unterschied gar nicht
so wirklich wahrnimmt. Und erst wenn man
danach im halben Jahr Usage
wieder das alte nimmt, dann merkt man es.
Aber bis jetzt.
Und die Helligkeit finde ich. Also das ist zumindest das
was ich aktuell habe.
Jetzt gucken wir mal was das 15er bringt.
Vielleicht heißt es 15
Ultra.
Es wird auf meinem Kanal
selbstverständlich. Es heißt Ultra?
Weil es nochmal 300 oder 400 Euro mehr kostet.
Da kannst du 3000 Euro oder so für einen
Smartphone dann ausgeben. Auf Reviews zu allen
vorgestellten iPhones geben und zwar so schnell
und so gut wie möglich. Ihr solltet ihn also
abonnieren, falls ihr das nicht verpassen wollt.
Alle iPhones sollen ein neues Design
vom Gehäuse bekommen, aber erwartet
jetzt nichts verrücktes.
Es wird eine eher dezente Änderung,
die ich mir aber sehr angenehm vorstelle.
Und zwar soll sowohl der
Rahmen als auch das Glas
insgesamt etwas runder werden.
Aber nicht so richtig rund wie früher.
Man kann es davon absehen, ich merke davon nichts,
weil ich habe eh eine Hülle drum und die Hülle
ist eigentlich auch recht runde. So richtig kantig wie jetzt,
sondern irgendwas dazwischen.
Das normale iPhone 15 ist 6,1
Zoll groß und das iPhone 15 Plus
wird 6,7 Zoll
groß sein. Und beide haben auf der Vorderseite
2,5 D Glas.
Ich muss ehrlich sagen,
6,1 Zoll ist für mich
das Maximum, was ich haben will
und gleichzeitig auch ziemlich
gute Größe.
Also größer geht nicht, weil ich
komme jetzt schon mit dem Daumen nicht mehr gescheit von oben
nach unten.
Und
es ist gerade
so groß wie geht, was auch für
mich die optimale Größe ist, weil mehr Display
immer besser. Glas ist zu den Seiten
leicht abgerundet. Bedeutet nicht,
dass das Display selbst abgerundet ist,
sondern nur das Glas, so wie das zum Beispiel
bei der Apple Watch der Fall ist. Dadurch soll es einfach
angenehmer sein, von den Seiten
oben und unten zu wischen. Dieses Video wurde
unterstützt durch Rhinoshield,
die natürlich auch wieder zu das iPhone 15
und 15 Pro die beste Hülle
hatte. Hatte das iPhone 11
nicht auch schon so ein abgerundetes
Glas?
...haben werden. Ihre Hüllen
zeichnen sich dadurch aus, dass sie extra
eine durchsichtige Hülle, außer dem Modul
für die 10 bekommt ihr die besten
Hülle.
Wenn schon eine Hülle, dann eine richtige
und zwar eine von Rhinoshield.
Beim iPhone 15 sollen zwei neue Farben
dazukommen. Ein relativ intensives
Babyblau und ein
sehr intensives ...
Ist dein iPhone 14 schwer?
Ja,
ich hab das mal
gewogen. Ich hab das
11er versus
das
14er gewogen.
Das 11er ist
minimal leichter,
irgendwie 10 Gramm
oder so.
Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich
an den fetten Kameras, die dran sind.
Rosa war es mich so ein bisschen
an Viva Magenta erinnert,
was ja die Farbe des Jahres 2023 ist.
Das Display auf der Vorderseite soll
jetzt endlich auch keine Notch
mehr haben, sondern die Dynamic Island,
die wir ja vom Pro-Modell kennen,
bedeutet ein langgezogenes Loch,
was eben aber auch interaktiv ist
und Widgets anzeigen kann.
Ansonsten ist das aber dasselbe Display,
bedeutet immer noch 60
Hertz, was
nur noch eine Unverschämtheit ist.
Also, ich gebe
ihm insofern Recht, es ist eine
Unverschämtheit bei dem Preis, wenn man das
mit den anderen vergleicht. Okay,
insgesamt ist es wunderbar
nutzbar mit 60 Hertz.
... darüber begründet werden kann, dass man ein bisschen
Marge rausholen wollte und
jetzt auch nicht irgendwie krass heller werden.
Und man muss
natürlich ja auch
einen,
wie soll man sagen, so einen Bonus
bieten, für die die noch mehr Geld ausgeben.
Was Neues können, ist einfach dasselbe Display,
nur mit der Dynamic Island drin.
Der Prozessor wird ein neuer werden
und zwar der Apple A16.
Der steckt ja jetzt gerade
im iPhone 14 Pro,
aber im iPhone 14
steckt halt gerade ein A15.
Das heißt, man ist immer eine Generation
hinter dem Pro sozusagen.
Ja, macht aber leistungsmäßig keinen großen Unterschied.
Also, es macht vielleicht in Benchmarks
einen Unterschied, aber fürs tägliche Benutzen
bezweifle ich, dass man das groß feststellt.
Der etwas schneller und etwas
energieeffizienter ist. Und die Kamera
soll auch 48 Megapixel bekommen,
wie das Pro-Modell, nur
einen nicht ganz so großen Sensor. Beim
Pro-Modell ist der ja 1 zu circa
1,3 Zoll groß
und hier ist er dann 1 zu 1,5 Zoll
groß. Das bedeutet aber erst trotzdem
größer als jetzt im iPhone 14
und dementsprechend werden wir schärfere und insgesamt
bessere Bilder haben. Weil die EU
Apple regelrecht gezwungen hat,
gibt es dieses Jahr zum ersten Mal im iPhone
endlich USB-C.
Darauf freue ich mich extrem.
Allerdings sagen die Gerüchte auch,
dass das normale iPhone 15
nur USB 2.0 Geschwindigkeit
be-
Apple, Alter!
USB 2.0!
Oh Gott!
Viel Spaß, da irgendwie
ein 35 Gigabyte Video runterzukopieren.
...PC bekommen soll, also nicht schneller
ist, als jetzt der Lightning-Port.
Viel spannender wird's natürlich... Ja, es ist jetzt
schon scheiße, vom iPhone was zu übertragen.
...vieler beim Pro-Modell. Und auch da gibt es
zwei Größen. Einmal 6,1 Zoll,
das wird das Pro, und 6,7
Zoll, also das Pro Max.
Wobei das auch Ultra heißen könnte,
weil das ein ganz relevantes Feature
mehr haben wird dieses Jahr.
Auch hier soll das Design insgesamt
runder werden, aber nicht nur das.
Die Kameras auf der Rückseite, die ja schon
jetzt wirklich gewaltig weit herausstehen,
das sind die am weitesten herausstehenden
Kameras, die ich kenne. Und sie sind auch
sonst sehr groß und massiv. Die sollen
noch mal größer werden und noch mal
weiter rausstehen. Boah!
Chocker-Kameras! Das dann noch gut aussieht
und wie das halt ist. Vor allem muss sie dir dann
wieder ein richtig fettes Case drumherum machen,
was die anderen Sachen dann in Frage stellt,
warum das so dünn ist.
Wenn das Gerät runterfällt,
aber das Gerät wird insgesamt etwas
stabiler werden, denn der Rahmen soll jetzt nicht
James Webb Telescope in der Hosentasche
bestehen,
sondern aus mattem Titan.
Also man muss sagen, dass die Kameras
von dem iPhone, was habe ich,
iPhone 14 Pro,
die sind
minimal besser als das, was man mit dem
Auge sehen kann.
Ich habe das letztens ausprobiert, da bin ich über einen Berg
gelaufen
und habe in der Entfernung so ein großes
Logistikzentrum-Gebäude gesehen, nicht
von Amazon. Und ich konnte
nie, also ich bin da schon öfters
lang gelaufen und ich konnte nie
lesen, was da drauf steht. Und jetzt
mit dem neuen iPhone habe ich das aufgemacht,
ran gesoomt
und ich konnte es ganz knapp lesen.
Also es ist minimal
besser als was man mit den Augen auflösen kann.
Erzähl nichts,
Brille für Max, ich habe 150%
Sehstärke, auf der einen
Seite zumindest.
Das ist einfach zu weit weg.
Und mit der Vergrößerung
und der vielleicht auch ein bisschen
Bildverbesserung, was auch immer da alles
läuft, mit dieser Magnifier
App,
konnte ich es tatsächlich gut
erkennen.
150%, ja.
Leichter,
was ich auf jeden Fall begrüße.
Wir sehen dann also ein etwas leichteres
und etwas ergonomischeres iPhone,
was nach dem 14 Pro, was
ja weder leicht noch ergonomisch war,
eine angenehme Abwechslung ist. Hier soll
die violette Farbe ersetzt werden.
Wisst ihr, wie man das misst, dass man 150%
Sehstärke hat?
Ich kann euch das erklären, ich warne mich beim
Optiker, da kann man ja so
Cook-Tests machen.
Okay, ich gebe zu, vielleicht
ist es mittlerweile auch schlechter, das ist schon wieder
sechs, sieben Jahre her, wo ich den Test gemacht habe.
Den Test habe ich gemacht, da war ich, keine Ahnung,
32, 31, 32,
vielleicht ist es jetzt mittlerweile schlechter, kann
durchaus sein. Zumindest, da geht es zum
Optiker und da musst du ja diese, diese,
da kriegst du
was angezeigt und dann musst du sagen,
was du da siehst, so. Und
ich habe alles
erkannt und dann,
dann hat er
etwa, etwa
ein Trick gezogen, also 100%
100% ist, wenn du
alles auf diese Normentfernung
erkennst.
Und auf einmal, ich habe
dann gesagt, ja, okay, das ist das, das ist das,
das ist das, ich weiß nicht mal, ob es
Öffnungen waren oder ob es Buchstaben waren,
ich weiß nicht mehr genau, zumindest, realagentsmith,
Dankeschön für den Sub. Und
dann habe ich alles erkannt und dann meint er, so,
jetzt wird es,
jetzt wird es anspruchsvoll oder sowas.
Und dann zieht er so einen Spiegel runter
und dann habe ich gesehen,
durch den Spiegel hinter mir
hing auch nochmal so ein Plakat.
Und dann sollte ich,
und dann sollte ich durch den Spiegel gucken,
ob ich das Plakat hinter mir erkenne.
Und da hatte ich meine Schwierigkeiten,
da habe ich nicht mehr alles erkannt, da habe ich glaube ich
irgendwie nur die oberen zwei Reihen oder
irgendwie sowas in der Richtung erkannt, da meinte er am Ende
150%.
Durch ein neues Dunkelrot
ist jetzt nicht so ganz mein Fall.
Ne, meins auch nicht.
Außerdem soll das das erste iPhone
Sieht aus, als hätte sich einer geschnitten
und sein iPhone vollgeblutet.
Das ist jetzt nicht so ganz
mein Fall. Außerdem soll das das erste
iPhone werden, was keine Tasten mehr hat.
Was?
Es klingt jetzt erstmal so, als könnte man es nicht mehr anmachen, aber es hat schon noch Tasten.
Es sind nur nicht richtige Tasten,
also keine, die man drücken kann.
Sondern welche, wo wenn man drauf drückt,
man ein Vibrationsfeedback kriegt,
das man gedrückt hat.
Ok, das was sie am Anfang auch mit dem Homebutton gemacht haben,
um dann den Homebutton abzuschaffen.
So wie das früher beim
Touch ID Fingerabdrucksensor war,
da wurde ja irgendwann auch kein Knopf mehr verbaut,
sondern er hat nur noch eine Kante.
Das hat tatsächlich ganz gut funktioniert.
HTC hatte sowas früher auch schon mal bei einem Smartphone,
das hat so semi gut funktioniert,
aber ich bin mir sicher, dass wenn es Apple macht, sie dafür
gute Gründe haben, wahrscheinlich wird das Gerät
deswegen sogar noch wasserfester sein.
Die haben die Gründe, dass man sich wahrscheinlich bewegliche Teile
spart, bewegliche Teile sparen ist
immer gut und am Endeffekt bringt es mehr Geld.
Letztendlich wird Apple mehr verdienen, das ist der Grund, warum
Apple Sachen macht.
Beim Display wird sich erstmal nichts verändern,
es ist wie gesagt gleich groß,
es hat die gleiche Auflösung, es hat auch eine Dynamic
Island und 120 Hertz,
aber es soll heller werden,
bis zu 2500 Nits,
was unglaublich hell ist
und es soll dünnere Displayränder geben.
1,5 mm dünn sollen sie sein
und damit wären es aktuell die dünnsten
auf dem Markt und das stelle ich mir
tatsächlich sehr sexy vor,
denn es würde ja auch bedeuten, dass das Gerät
ein kleines bisschen kompakter wird.
Touch ID kommt leider nicht ins Display,
aber es wird jetzt endlich
so sein, dass wir auch hier
USB-C bekommen und hier dann sogar
in Thunderbolt 3 Geschwindigkeit
heißt sehr sehr schnell.
Aber dann nur für das Highend-Modell,
was mindestens 1500 Euro kostet.
Aber auch die Gerüchte, dass es spezielle
zertifiziert für iPhone
Kabel geben wird.
Na was denn auch sonst?
Was denn auch sonst?
Da kann man doch nicht einfach jedes
x beliebige USB-Kabel anschließen,
dass das funktioniert.
Ne, ne, ne, so was geht bei Apple
selbstverständlich nicht. Man braucht ein
offizielles zertifiziertes
70 Euro Apple USB 3 Kabel,
damit das funktioniert.
Ich glaube, man muss sich da nicht
extreme sorgen.
Ja gehen wird das zum Laden,
aber zum schnell übertragen.
Ne, ne, ne, von der EU wurde das
nicht verboten. Von der EU wurde das mit
USB-C vorgeschrieben und das
ja, connectbar,
ladbar über USB-C ist.
Nicht, dass du die volle Geschwindigkeit mit
jedem dahergelaufenen Kabel über USB-C
kriegst. Also Apple kann durchaus
Spezialkabel anbieten,
dass die schnelle Datenübertragung funktioniert.
Was unsinnig ist, jedes billige
China-Chinesen-Kabel kann ordentlich
Daten übertragen, aber Apple sagt
Nope.
Die haben auch diese
speziellen Made-for-Apple-Kabel
untersagt.
Also wenn das Apple macht, dann haben die bestimmt
irgendein Schlupfloch da drin gefunden.
Ich nehme mal an, das bezieht sich auf
die Thunderbolt 3 Geschwindigkeit, die
einfach nicht jedes Kabel unterstützt
und diese Zertifizierung soll dann ein bisschen
Einfachheit in die Lage reinbringen,
aber klar, natürlich konnte Apple
nicht einfach ein iPhone mit USB-C rausbringen
ohne eine extra Wurst zu machen.
Der Prozessor im iPhone 15 Pro
wird der neue A17 sein
und der soll in 3 Nanometer
gefertigt sein und deswegen wird er
etwa 10 bis 15% schneller sein,
aber vor allem etwa 30%
energieeffizierter.
Das sind natürlich großartige Nachrichten,
weil es bedeutet, dass die Akkulaufzeit
viel besser werden kann.
Aber die Gerüchte sind halt auch, dass man für diese
Na gut, dafür wird das Display heller, das frisst das
dann wieder auf.
...neuen Tasten einen größeren oder sogar
einen zweiten Vibrationsmotor braucht
und dadurch muss der Akku dann kleiner werden
und das bedeutet, dass Apple vielleicht den Akku kleiner macht
und somit die Laufzeit am Ende dieselbe ist.
Der Arbeitsspeicher wird
anwachsender auf 8GB, wahrscheinlich aber nicht,
weil das iPhone mehr Arbeitsspeicher braucht,
sondern wegen den Kameras.
Und weil man wahrscheinlich
gerade Speichersachen
auch immer gut den Leuten anpreisen kann.
Überlegt man, wie
unsinnig teuer die
Flashspeicher in Handys sind.
...gibt es auch ein paar
Verbesserungen. So richtig genau sind
die Gerüchte noch nicht. Ich würde aber
fast vermuten, dass alle 3 Sensoren
jetzt 48 Megapixel haben.
Die Hauptkamera hatte das ja schon
und ich nehme auch an, dass der Sensor
da unverändert bleiben wird.
Vielleicht wird jedoch die Blende größer,
weil wenn die Kamera weiter raus steht,
kann die Blende theoretisch
etwas größer werden und
es wird eine neue Periscope-Kamera kommen
und die soll 5-fach Verlust...
Nochmal eine Kamera!
Alter, wie viele Kameras...
Okay, Moment, seriously. Ich guck grad hinten
auf mein iPhone drauf. Ich hab da jetzt
schon 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6 Löcher
in dem Gehäuse für irgendwelche
Kamerageschichten, ja?
Und dann hast du 7. Oder wie?
Guck hier. 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6...
Wait a minute.
Das sieht genau so aus
wie bei mir.
Ich hab nix gesagt. Das sieht genau so aus
...frei zoomen. Die Gerüchte sagen,
Periscope-Kamera kommen
und die soll 5-fach Verlust
frei zoomen. Ah, 5-fach zoomen, nicht
noch 3-fach zoomen wie bei mir.
Die Gerüchte sagen, zwischen 5-fach und 10-fach.
Ich glaube aber leider...
Also 10-fach optisch wäre natürlich
krass mit so einer kleinen Kamera.
Wie willst du da das Objektiv einbauen?
5-fach dürfte wahrscheinlich
reichen. Nicht, dass Apple eine variable
Kamera verbauen wird, wie das Sony zum Beispiel
tut, sondern so machen wir aktuell ein iPhone,
wo sie sagen, wenn man bei 48
Megapixel 2-fach
vergrößert, dann landet man wieder bei 12
Megapixel. Also es ist Verlustfrei.
Ich nehme an, dass diese Periscope-Kamera
auch 48 Megapixel hat
und wenn man dann auf 10-fach vergrößert,
hat sie ja immer noch 12 und ist dadurch Verlustfrei.
So sagt es Google auch beim
Pixel und die Ergebnisse sind super.
Also ein 5-fach Verlustfreier Zoom
wäre großartig. Wegen Platzgründen
soll er aber wahrscheinlich nur im
Pro Max bzw. dem Ultra-Gerät
drin sein. Die aktuellen Gerüchte
und Apple hat das selbst auch schon angedeutet,
sind leider, dass die Preise...
Kann man damit bis zum Mond zoomen? Nee, dafür brauchst du
Samsung.
Das ist dann zwar nicht der echte Mond, den du fotografiert hast,
sondern der replaced wurde,
aber es sieht cool aus.
Steigenwerten. Jetzt sind sie
halt letztes Jahr in Deutschland schon um 150
Euro gestiegen und da hieß es
eigentlich nicht, dass sie steigen sollen, weil sie
in Amerika ja nicht gestiegen sind, aber der Euro
war halt im Verhältnis zu schwach.
Jetzt ist wirklich die Frage, ob
der Preis vielleicht einfach gleich bleibt und wir machen uns
nur einfach unnötig verrückt und wir sind dann total
erleichtert und finden auf einmal 1300 Euro
Also ehrlich gesagt, ich gehe davon aus,
es wird keinen großartig interessieren.
Wer jetzt schon ohne mit der Wimper
zu zucken 1500 Euro für
sein Smartphone ausgibt, der gibt auch
1600 Euro ohne mit der
Wimper zu zucken für sein Smartphone aus.
Es hätte ja auch noch teurer sein können
oder ob die Preise halt tatsächlich
steigen und aktuell kostet
das iPhone 14 Pro
halt leider schon 1300 Euro.
Das heißt, wenn die Preise nochmal um
die angekündigten 10 bis 15
Prozent steigen, dann landen wir
halt bei ca. 1500 Euro.
Du bist das beste Beispiel, warum
ich gebe kaum Geld aus.
20 GB Speicher, das
wäre schon wirklich, wirklich heftig und
auch die normalen iPhones sollen ein Stück teurer
werden. Dadurch werden sie alle
wirklich, ja sie sind ja jetzt schon
krass teuer, einfach nochmal so viel teurer, dass ich
wirklich nicht weiß, wie ich dazu
fühlen soll bzw. ich weiß, wie ich dazu
fühle. Er kauft sich ein. Aber
irgendwo ist es halt auch zu erwarten. Was haltet ihr vom
iPhone 15 Pro? Werdet ihr es euch kaufen
und wenn ja, welches Modell und warum
und auf welches Feature freut ihr euch am meisten?
Auf die neuen Tasten, auf die Periscope
Kamera oder... So wirklich was
superspannendes Neues war jetzt da nicht dabei,
oder? Die neue
Kamera finde ich jetzt auch
nicht so nice, wenn es dadurch das
Gehäuse noch klobischer wird.
Eigentlich nicht wirklich was am Start,
also nichts, was mich jetzt irgendwie schockt, wo ich
sagen würde, oh ja, ich brauche unbedingt dieses
Jahr noch wieder mal ein neues Smartphone.
Was ganz anderes, schreibt mir das mal in die Kommentare
und macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ciao!
Okay.
Ist mein Browser
wieder kaputt?
Ich glaube, mein Browser ist wieder kaputt. Ich mach
den mal neu auf.
Browser hat sich verabschiedet. Zu viele
Tabs.
Nee, nee.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Ah ja, das wollte ich, das wollte ich gestern schon gucken.
Jaja, die gucke ich gerne, die Videos.
Da werde ich mal gespannt, was die Leute
wieder gebastelt haben.
Die gucke ich immer gerne.
Welches Smartphone
könnte man jetzt kaufen? Nicht zu teuer.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Ich kenne mich
was Android-Smartphones angeht überhaupt nicht aus.
Ich habe zwar sowohl iOS-Geräte als
auch Android-Geräte, aber ich habe kein aktuelles
Android-Smartphone.
Also, ich kann dir da
nichts zu sagen.
China-Chinesen-Xiaomi ist ganz gut.
Von denen habe ich mir einen smarten
Pad-Fountain gekauft. Nee, bei mir muss ich heute mal
gucken, wie ich das Ding ins WLAN kriege.
Okay.
Schauen wir mal.
Ihr mit Smartphone-Sensoren
so und so angestellt habt. Wir inspirieren uns wieder
gegenseitig und finden vielleicht
eigene verrückte Ideen. Und durch die Magie
Auf geht's.
Heute schauen wir uns an, was ihr mit Smartphone-Sensoren
so und so angestellt habt. Wir inspirieren uns
wieder gegenseitig und finden vielleicht
eigene verrückte Ideen. Und durch die Magie
Was zum?
Wir inspirieren uns wieder gegenseitig.
Also das hier, das kann ich mir noch vorstellen.
Das ist so ein Ultraschall-Sensor.
Sieht zumindest so aus.
Äh, hallo?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Das da, das sieht aus wie so ein Ultraschall-Sensor.
Wahrscheinlich, wo einer
unterm Schreibtisch guckt, ob jemand
am Tisch sitzt oder sowas.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal. Mal gucken, ob wir recht haben.
Wir inspirieren uns wieder gegenseitig
und finden vielleicht eigene...
Und was das hier sein soll?
Irgendein, irgendein Abgas-
Mess-Sensor oder sowas?
Egal, wir werden es ja gleich erfahren.
Durch die Magie des Videoschnitts habe ich die Beiträge
nachträglich so sortiert,
dass die immer exotischere
Sensoren zeigen. Oder die Sensoren
immer mehr zweckentfremdet werden.
Oder da muss ich ja mit den Übergängen aufpassen, ne?
Und mir wirklich überlegen,
was ich wann referenzieren kann.
Es könnte auch, es könnte tatsächlich auch
ein Jep-Cock-Sensor sein.
Wirklich. Oder ich behaupte einfach nur,
dass ich das so gemacht habe, damit du bis zum Ende
dranbleibst. Menschentiere-Automation,
Ausgabe 17.
Ich hab, äh, ich hab keinen
Überblick mehr. Es geht los mit Markus
und seiner Fernsehautomation. Auf geht's, Markus.
Und zwar haben wir bei uns im Wohnzimmer einen 75
Zoll LG-Fernseher verbaut.
Der wurde auf einem
Fernsehlift montiert, da uns das ziemlich
Ein Fernsehlift?
Ich...
Also ich hab ja auch, ich hab ja auch im Wohnzimmer
nen...
Was hab ich denn? 72 Zoll?
65 Zoll? 75 Zoll?
Ich glaub 70? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich hab ja im Wohnzimmer auch einen recht großen Fernseh stehen.
Und es ist schon
ein bisschen doof, dass
einfach ne riesen
schwarze Box im Endeffekt da steht,
wenn da nichts an ist. Allerdings,
so schlimm finde ich das jetzt auch
wieder nicht, dass ich den Aufwand betreiben
würde, das Teil irgendwie hoch
und runter zu fahren.
Allerdings,
an sich ist es ne coole Sache, weil ich hab im
Wohnzimmer eh schon
so nen Schrank stehen.
Da könnte man das wunderbar
dahinter verstauen.
Was kostet denn ein
Fernsehlift?
Und wie hoch
kann der liften?
Und kann man den vor allem ordentlich steuern?
Ok, so irgendwie 300 Euro?
Ein Fernsehlift?
Naja, schauen wir mal.
Dass man vor einem großen schwarzen Kasten
guckt, wenn man in das Wohnzimmer ankommt.
Leider ist an dem Fernsehlift
nur ein Kippschalter verbaut,
den man gedrückt halten muss,
damit der Fernseher hoch bzw. runter
fährt. Und da
ich nicht jünger werde und
keine Zeit hab, über 20 Sekunden
den Schalter gedrückt zu halten, habe ich die
ganze Geschichte automatisiert. Und die
möchte ich euch jetzt zeigen. Das würde ich als allererste
auch machen.
Markus, du musst das nicht mit deinem Alter entschuldigen.
Wir sind hier heute alle versammelt,
weil niemand von uns Schalter 20 Sekunden
drücken möchte. Und außerdem sind wir alle
Faulersfuck. Hier darf jeder
automatisieren, was er oder sie
für richtig hält. Und er ist recht, wenn ein Schalter
20 Sekunden gedrückt werden will.
Face leak.
Moment, man muss
es auch noch aufklappen?
Okay, da hätte ich keinen Bock drauf,
wenn ich da noch rumklappen müsste.
Ich würde sogar noch einen Schritt weitergehen.
Ich habe genau gesehen, dass du die
Globus... Globusse?
Globen? Du hast die von Hand runtergestellt
und du hast von Hand die Kisten aufgemacht.
In meinen Augen
solltest du jetzt eher losgehen und dir
irgendwelche linearen Motoren oder was auch immer.
Dass das automatisch geht?
Damit die Schränke auch automatisch aufgehen
und die Globusgeschichte
vielleicht mit irgendeinem Seilzugding
lösen.
Man sieht, das Zimmer wird dunkler.
Das wurde über Rademacher
Gurtwickler
gebaut.
Da habe ich auch so ein Ding,
habe ich nicht im Einsatz
breitflächig. Ich habe das mal ausprobiert,
hat nicht richtig gut funktioniert,
diese automatischen Rollladenöffnungsdinger.
Also diese klassischen
mit dem Gurt.
Wenn man den Rollladen hat mit Motor
schon drin, ist es wieder was anderes.
Viel zu laut,
das ist doch kein Problem.
Erstens hört sich das wahrscheinlich
laut an, weil sein Mikrofon
über das Laut eingestellt ist
und das sind halt 10 Sekunden oder 20 Sekunden,
wo das hochfährt. Das kann man die Lautstärke
nochmal ertragen.
Nur, dass es ein FireTV ist,
das geht mir schon mal nicht in die
Bude.
Okay, das war ja noch eine
relativ zahme Geschichte.
Ein Fensterkontakt in der Klappe,
automatische Gurtwickler finde ich
grundsätzlich auch interessant, aber ich muss
ja trotzdem Strom dahin legen, oder sehe ich das falsch?
Nö, siehst du richtig.
Vielleicht, aber dann geht es nicht
lang.
Ganz interessant fürs Nachrüsten.
Wollen wir doch mal sehen, ob Philipp seine
Sensoren noch ein bisschen mehr an die
Grenzen bringt.
Der Titel verspricht es, Sensormissbrauch
ist mir sehr sympathisch.
Das ist unser Kamin und der ist in Verbindung
mit einer zentralen Lüftungsanlage von 10 da,
welche, ich glaube vor
zweieinhalb Jahren, glaube ich,
neu gekommen ist. Und einer
Abluft-Lunzabzugshaube in der
Küche, ein etwas schwierigeres
Konstrukt.
Das wird jeder
Schornsteinfeger bestätigen können, der kriegt dann meist
Schweißperlen auf der Stirn.
Die Haube soll ja natürlich nicht das
CO aus dem Teil
in den Wohnbereich ziehen.
Das ergibt schon ein bisschen Sinn.
Dann haben wir die Auflage bekommen, dass die
Dunzabzugshaube einen Schalter haben
muss, dass die nicht funktioniert,
wenn kein Fenster
geöffnet ist.
Es war uns aber zu uns smart, wir wollten gerne
diese Regelung nur dann
einsetzen müssen, wenn der auch wirklich
befeuert ist. Und das haben wir so gelöst.
Das Rauchgasrohr hat hier einen
Rauchgas-Thermostat, so heißt das in der Westen
speziell, von Cetro Tech.
Das ist eine deutsche Firma,
die mit einem Dorn hier reinführt.
Und das
je nachdem, wie sich das ausdehnt,
da gibt es dann auch unterschiedliche Varianten. Das ist so eine ab
50 Grad schaltet der dann, also
öffnet oder schließt. Da gibt es, glaube ich, auch unterschiedliche Varianten.
Und dann kriegt das hier
ein Hometic
für den Fensterkontakt mit. Und dieser
geht dann die CCU und die gibt das wiederum weiter
an meinen I.O. Broker.
Und...
Ach, der Schalter,
dann wird das magnetisch und der
Home-Kontakt... Okay, das hätte ich anders
gelöst. Ich hätte nicht so einen extra Fensterkontakt
hingemacht.
Zumindest nicht mit an die Wand.
Das hätte ich mir irgendwas anderes überlegt.
Irgendein ESP mit Relay,
weil Strom braucht das Ding ja eh.
Damit weiß ich
auf jeden Fall erstmal, wann der befeuert ist.
Das funktioniert auch ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich gut.
Exzellent funktioniert das.
Spätestens nach zwei, zweieinhalb Minuten
beim Anfeuern von diesem Kamin ist das schon
geschaltet. Also da sind die 50 Grad schon erreicht.
Der Schanzerfeger hat das abgenommen tatsächlich
und das funktioniert so gut, dass wir sogar unterscheiden können
bei der Dunstabzugshaube ist nur Licht an,
denn wir haben da einfach einen Zündestecker zwischen...
Wie warm wird denn das Rohr?
Kriegt man das nicht einfach auch mit einem normalen
Dings? Wie heißt das Teil?
BS28?
Nee.
TS28?
Wie heißt dieses Ding?
DS!
Das meine ich.
Nein, das meine ich.
Die Dinger meine ich.
DS18B20.
Dieses Teil.
Kriegt man das nicht mit so einem billigen
1€ AliExpress-Teil auch hin?
Weil das Rohr...
Das Rohr wird zu heiß.
Aber...
Wenn das Rohr schon zu heiß wird,
wie heiß ist denn der Rauch erst da drin?
Oder meinst du, das Rohr wird halt so heiß,
dass der Sensor im Endeffekt
außerhalb der
Betriebsspezifikation quasi
für den Sensor ist?
Was schafft der denn?
Ja, okay, guck mal.
Der kann plus maximal 125°C.
Das reicht wahrscheinlich nicht.
Das Rohr wird wahrscheinlich eine ganze Ecke wärmer
als 125°C.
Okay, verstehe, verstehe.
Und das andere Ding ist im Endeffekt darauf ausgelegt,
dass es so hohe Temperaturen abkann.
Ah, Chet, ihr seid high IQ.
Stimmt.
Wenn das Feuer aus ist, bleibt das Rohr
noch lange warm, aber die Schaltung sollte
wieder aus sein.
Aha.
Dann ergibt das tatsächlich
Sinn,
über die Rauchtemperatur zu machen.
Weil, naja,
wenn der Ofen dann wirklich aus ist, dann ist die
Rauchtemperatur halt auch schneller wieder weg,
als das Rohr kalt ist.
High IQ, Chet.
Okay, dann
verstehe ich, warum man so gemacht hat.
Welcher, die können bei der...
Der Schadensabzugshaube hat das abgenommen tatsächlich
und das funktioniert so gut, dass wir sogar unterscheiden
können, bei der Dunstabzugshaube ist nur Licht an,
denn wir haben da einfach einen Zwischenstecker
zwischengesteckt, welcher den Verbrauch misst
und alles unter einem gewissen Wert,
wie nur das Licht an ist.
Das ist eine Dunstabzugshaube, die würde mir
nicht gefallen. Ich mag
tatsächlich Schalter
an solchen Geräten und nicht nur
Touch. Das ist generell so ein Unding.
Ich verstehe gar nicht, warum diese
Dinger wirklich gut
funktionierende,
spürbare, fühlbare, vor allem
auch ein- und ausschalt-sehbare
Knöpfe hatten,
durch Touch ersetzt
wird.
Bleibt der Strom
eingeschaltet und wenn das
befeuert ist und sobald ich den Motor
einschalte und das sogar auch ohne Licht,
der verbraucht immer mehr als das Licht,
dann schaltet einfach die Steckdose ab
und die Dunstabzugshaube ist quasi vom Herz genommen.
Und sobald ich den Fenster wieder aufmache,
ist sofort die Dunstabzugshaube wieder nutzbar.
Ziemlich cool.
Das löst tatsächlich ein Problem, über das ich noch nie
nachgedacht habe. Veranlasst
mich aber auch...
Was ist, wenn der
Fensterkontakt, wenn
die Batterie leer ist vom Fensterkontakt?
Dann funktioniert das nicht.
Und wenn die Zentrale,
die diese Steuerung macht, der Dings
nicht da ist, dann funktioniert es auch nicht.
Das ist ja nichts Autarkes.
Dieses Verlangen,
in unserer Ofenrohr auch so einen Sensor zu bauen.
Ich meine, wenn das eine Sache ist, die ich
messen und darauf
reagieren kann, warum messe ich das nicht
und reagiere da nicht drauf? Technisch.
Ich versuche mal den Sensor zu finden und
die ganzen anderen Geräte auch und die findet ihr in der
Videobeschreibung, soweit ich sie gefunden habe.
Aber Philipp hat offenbar noch mehr... Wenn das der Schornsteinfeger
sieht, da hat er überhaupt keine Probleme. Der hat auch gesagt,
der Schornsteinfeger fand das sogar nice.
So ein Ding habe ich auch.
Sogar zwei
Lebendfang Mäusefallen, weil wir hatten mal
Mäuse im Stall.
Und von unserer Katze
kannst du nicht erwarten, dass sie die Mäuse fängt.
Hast du mal einen Videolink?
Du musst einfach suchen nach eurer
Tom-Automation. Das Video ist von gestern. Spiel
und Zeug. Findest du easy
innerhalb von zwei Minuten.
So einen Teil habe ich auch. Allerdings habe ich das nicht
smart gemacht. Ich bin dann einfach morgens in den
Stall und habe geguckt, ob was drinne
ist in der Mäusefall. Und ihr glaubt nicht,
die Mäuse sind wie verrückt in diese
Mäusefallen reingerennt. Man würde jetzt
ja vermuten, es dauert lange,
bis man alle Mäuse gefangen hat. Nee, innerhalb
von einer Woche oder so hatten wir alle
Mäuse gefangen.
Es war eine, war hartnäckig,
aber die isst dann auch. Irgendwann hat sie
Hunger und ist dann da rein.
Seitdem sind wir mausfrei
im Stall. Wobei,
waren wir vielleicht. Vielleicht gibt es ja wieder welche.
Was hast du dann mit denen gemacht?
Das darf ich jetzt nicht so laut sagen.
Ich habe sie ausgesetzt
auf, ähm, ich bin...
Ich habe die, ich habe die mit, ich habe die
mit Kindern, die haben die in so eine, so eine...
Plastikbehälter gepackt,
habe die eingepackt,
ins Auto, bin
an Stadtrand gefahren
und habe sie dort in
in so einem Schrebergarten oder so in so einem
Gebiet, wo viele Schrebergärten sind, ausgesetzt.
Also wahrscheinlich haben die auf einmal
jetzt in den Schrebergärten Mäuse, wo vorher
keine waren.
Und wer weiß,
die wievielte Maus-Generation,
für die wievielte Maus-Generation
ich damit die Grundlage gelegt habe.
Das ist bestimmt schon in der 8. Generation dort.
Die Mäuse fallen stehen ja
meist an Orten, wo man nicht so
häufig ist.
Sei es Spitzboden, Gartenhäuser
oder Garage oder so.
Da müsste man dann halt jedes Mal
regelmäßig hinlaufen, dass man
dieser Maus keiner unnötigen
Qual aussetzt.
Und da habe ich dann einfach einen Xiaomi
Tür- und Fensterkontakt reingepackt.
Gute Idee, sofern man dort
ZigBee-Empfang hat.
Sobald die auslöst, öffnet der,
sendet...
Coole Sache, coole Idee, coole Idee.
Und der wiederum hat einen Skript, dass er
dann über Push-Over mir
an mein Handy eine Push-Benachrichtigung
sendet.
Perfekt, damit haben wir ja
zumindest indirekt die Tiere aus dem Titel
dieser Serie auch in dem Video.
Aber ja, also die Idee ist tatsächlich
fantastisch und ich frage mich ein bisschen,
warum ich da nicht dran gedacht habe, als wir
letztes Jahr auch Lebenfallen bei uns ins Gartenhaus
gestellt haben und dann jeden Morgen
und Abend mit den Kindern da einmal hingedackelt sind.
Ich meine, das war natürlich auch ein Programmpunkt.
Ganz davon abgesehen, ich meine, das ist
2,50 Meter
laufen oder 10 Meter laufen.
Da kann man doch einmal am Tag reingucken.
Ich finde es eine coole Sache, aber nachdem ich
nicht dauerhaft Mäusefallen bei mir stehen habe,
brauche ich es nicht.
Ich habe das bisher als Eimer gebraucht.
Aber im Zweifel wartet
die Maus dann auch recht lange auf ihre Abholung.
So ist das natürlich
viel sinnvoller, denn warum soll man
in Ungewissheit leben, ob man eine Maus
gefangen hat und warum soll die Maus
unnötig lange darauf warten, dass man
mit ihr macht, was auch immer man danach
mit ihr macht. So, dann
Philipp, noch was? Ja, und als letztes befinde
ich mich hier an unserem Gaszähler
und vielleicht
sind es ja auch meine Mäuse in seinem Gartenhaus
gewesen.
Hier unten so eine Buchse, an
dem so ein Impulszähler rein kann.
Den gibt es da irgendwie fertig zu kaufen,
auch direkt vom Hersteller oder so. Ich bin mir gar nicht ganz
sicher. Auf jeden Fall kann man auch mit
einem aus dem Herr gebauten
Xiaomi Tür- und Fenster-Kontakt. Ja, das geht.
Das geht. Das habe
ich auch schon gesehen irgendwo. Ich glaube,
auf Reddit gesehen. Das wusste ich, dass das
prinzipiell funktioniert. So gut da rein, dass der
klemmen bleibt, kann man einfach die Impulse
abnehmen und ich kann mir dann hier
die Impulse von dem Kubikmeter auf
in mein Smart Home reinlesen.
Coole Sache. Und weiß so,
wenn ich einmal den Grundwert, von dem ich
starte, reingehe, weiß ich immer genau,
auf welchem Kubikmeter werde ich auch stehen.
Verrückt. Ich habe mich gefragt, was da gerade
irgendwie heraushängt. Und verrückt, wo du
dir überall Fenstersensoren hinsteckst.
Das ist auf jeden Fall sehr schön. Also
die Idee, damit die Impulse eines Zählers abzulesen.
Fenstersensoren hinstecken ist
beste Taktik.
Ich kenne jetzt die Lösung, die
viele von euch im Einsatz
haben, dass man irgendwie mit einer kleinen Raspberry Pi
Kamera oder so den eigentlichen
Zähler anguckt und dann mit einer Texte
... Ja, das ist...
Das ist Mist. Also
ich würde überall dort, wo ich
per Magnet, Kontakt, wie auch immer,
den Wert abgreifen
kann, würde ich das immer in so einer
selbstgebastelten Bilderkennung vorziehen.
Das einzige, wo ich das eben nicht machen kann,
das habe ich euch ja gestern schon erzählt, ist an
meiner Heizungs-, an meinem Manometer an
der Heizung. Und das versuche ich ja
über AI auszulesen,
in der Hoffnung, dass Chat GPT-4 oder
GPT-4 endlich mal Image Input erlaubt.
Obwohl sie damit geworben haben,
aber es bis heute nicht haben.
Oder wir bauen wirklich mit OpenCV
was selbst. Wobei ich
eigentlich legit
keinen Bock habe, etwas selbst
zu bauen.
Ja.
So ist es.
Guckt, was da drauf steht.
Und wenn du auch wie Philipp Sensoren
ungewöhnlich einsetzt, oder wenn du was anderes
Spannendes für dein Smartphone oder drum herum
gebaut hast, dann schicken wir einfach ein kurzes
Video. Alles, was du wissen musst, findest du unter
zeug.coolslash.zeigen. Und wenn
ich das verwende, gibt es einen 50-Euro-Amazon-Gutschein
für dich.
Wir machen das nicht mit OpenCV.
Wir machen das, wenn schon, mit irgendeinem selbst
trainierten PyTorch-Model
oder sonst was. Also mit PyTorch
mit irgendeinem selbst trainierten Model.
Dann mache ich einfach ein paar Bilder
und lasse die dann
verschiedene Startti
von der Kamera lernen.
Dann mal gucken, ob das geht.
Was bringt dir der aktuelle
Stand über das Wissen des Zählers? Moment.
Ich rede nicht von dem
Zählerstand. Ich rede von der Druckanzeige
meiner Heizung.
Und das bringt mir tatsächlich was zu wissen. Nämlich
ob die Heizung noch morgen funktionieren wird oder
ob ich erstmal Druck nachfüllen muss. Druck
also Wasser nachfüllen muss.
Wasser nachfüllen ist bei mir mittlerweile relativ
einfach gelöst. Ich habe so
ein automatisches
automatisch schaltbares Ventil.
Das haben wir
sogar gebaut im Stream irgendwann mal.
Da ist ein ESP32 drinne.
Und der macht das Ventil
für die Wasserzufuhr auf und zu.
Das kann ich auf Remote schalten.
Kein Überdruckventil.
So in so einem
So ein Teil ist das.
Sieht ein bisschen so aus wie das hier.
Also das
ist im Endeffekt hier oben ein Motor.
Da habe ich einen ESP32
reingebaut, dran gelötet, dass man das nicht
mit dieser doofen
App machen muss.
Ich habe einen eigenen ESP32
dran gelötet.
An die
Relay-Kontakte
für den Motor.
Ja und jetzt mache ich den Motor an und aus.
Easy.
Und dann dreht das das Ding auf und zu.
Also damit mache ich Wasserdruck
für die Heizung nachfüllen.
Also Wasser nachfüllen für die Heizung.
Jetzt müsste ich halt nur noch automatisch
irgendwie auslesen können, welchen
Wasserdruck man hat. Aktuell mache ich das mit einer Kamera.
Da muss man halt drauf gucken.
Ja. Also du weißt schon.
Hallo Andreas. Ich habe eine smarte
Badezimmerautomation
gebastelt. Dafür brauche ich einmal
ein smartes Thermostat von Tado.
Ein
Akara Türsensor, also Fenstersensor.
Ist aber
ist es nur mein Ohr oder ist der Typ nur
auf der rechten Seite?
Noch zwei Sensoren am Fenster
von Akara.
Ein
Wassersensor von Akara, der ist in der
Dusche. Eine Alexa,
die habe ich hinter der Badezimmerautomation.
Alter was komplizierter ist der da.
Vielleicht steht euch darauf hinzuweisen, dass ihr vielleicht eure Smart Speaker
die Mikrophone
ausschalten solltet für dieses Verband.
Einen smarten Lichtschalter
beziehungsweise
hinter dem Lichtschalter
ein Shelly verbaut, der medizinisch
schalten kann. Oh das ist ja.
Okay das wirkt äußerst
gut aus, was er da gebaut hat.
Ich habe das natürlich absichtlich bei Dunkelheit gedreht.
Wie verbinden das sich mit dem ESP?
Äh
gar nicht. Du meinst
hier meine
das Teil meinst du
wie das sich mit dem ESP verbindet. Der verbindet sich
gar nicht mit dem ESP. Ich habe den ESP
hier rein gebaut und angelötet
an die Kontakte für den Motor.
Warte mal.
Archiv.
Rätsel.
Nee.
Motor.
Hof-Tor-Steuerung.
Nee das war was anderes gewesen.
Hier Smart Ventil.
Fuck.
Jaja Max ist gut.
Äh hier sieht man das.
Falls man das sieht.
Wenn man nicht im Fullscreen. Wenn ich es im Fullscreen habe.
Okay da habe ich
noch nichts.
Wir müssten mal wieder ein bisschen basteln oder?
Kann das sein?
Äh
Ja man
erkennt. Ah hier. Hier erkennt man es doch ganz gut.
Wie das
wie das alles angelötet ist. Guck ich habe das
hier an die Kontakte dran gemacht.
Das hier ist der Motor.
Bin ich ganz sicher wie
ich es jetzt genau gemacht habe.
Ich vermute
ja ich habe genau.
Ich habe den ESP da standardmäßig drauf
verabgelötet. Und habe dann meinen
eigenen ESP. Ist übrigens kein ESP32
das ist ein 2866.
An die jeweiligen Kontakte angelötet.
Und dann ist das Motor drauf.
Das Motor. Und das
macht die Steuerung. Also gehe ich gar nicht
per W laden drauf. Beziehungsweise mein Home Assistant drauf.
Und das
an und ausschalten.
Ja so funktioniert das.
Duschen gehen. Dafür mache ich einmal meine Tür zu.
Die Fenster mache ich in der Regel
auf. Lasse ich jetzt aber auch nochmal
zu. Denn das wird gleich
auch noch zum Thema werden. Damit du
bei Dunkelheit im hell
erleuchteten Badezimmer mit offenen Fenster
damit die ganze Nachbarschaft einen nackten Mann
sieht. Und wir sehen uns dann wieder
wenn ich fertig bin mit Duschen.
Nachdem wir jetzt Duschen machen und der Boden
auch noch ordentlich nass ist.
Wollen wir natürlich gehen.
Bitte öffnen nach dem Duschen das Fenster.
Alles klar.
Hat erkannt, dass die Fenster zu sind.
Dann machen wir die zum Lüften einfach
mal auf. Okay das ist tatsächlich ganz
gut, dass man daran erinnert wird.
Und
jetzt warten wir nochmal 10 Minuten. Können uns
frisch machen. Können uns vielleicht, wenn wir eine Frau sind,
im kalten Bad
dann erstmal frisch machen. Nice.
Hier darf sich schminken,
wer auch immer sich schminken möchte.
Ey guck mal, der hat die gleiche
Waage wie ich.
Hier darf sich schminken, wer auch immer sich schminken möchte.
Xiaomi Mi Scale.
Sehen wir uns wieder.
Beste.
So jetzt sind etwa 10 Minuten
rum. Wir sind fertig geduscht.
Haben die Zähne geputzt, haben uns fertig
gemacht. Unser Licht am Spiegel
ist angegangen. Das liegt einfach daran,
weil es draußen dunkel ist.
Damit der Roboter, der jetzt Dusche
wischen möchte. Was?
Dusche wischen? Mit dem Roboter?
Ja, weil der ja mit einer Kamera operiert.
Alter.
Hm.
High IQ Shit.
Roboter ist jetzt fertig mit Dusche wischen.
Fährt wieder auf seine. Der wischt aber
nur den Boden. Das wo es schimmelt
ist meistens an der Wand und in den Ecken,
wenn er zu viel Wasser sich
angesammelt hat.
Der Boden
dürfte wahrscheinlich gar nicht so sehr das Problem sein.
Homebase.
Und das Licht ist
wieder ausgegangen.
So und jetzt kommen wir einmal zur Automation. Das Ganze läuft
bei mir über Open Hub. Der Wasser
sind so erkennt.
Open Hub Java.
Das wird aber noch einmal abgeglichen
mit dem Raumthermostat. Das Raumthermostat
hat überprüft, ob innerhalb der letzten
20 Minuten die Luftfeuchtigkeit
signifikant gestiegen ist.
Ja ok, das klingt sinnvoll aus. Weil wenn du duschen eigentlich der Fall
ist, wenn wir zum Beispiel eine große Vase
oder so in der Dusche sauge machen und der Wassersensor
Wasser abbekommt, dann erkennt
das System noch nicht, ob wir geduscht haben.
Die Alexa warnt uns,
wenn die Fenster geschlossen sind, dass wir
die Fenster doch bitte aufmachen sollen, einfach damit
die Luftfeuchtigkeit rausgeht. Wenn die
Luftfeuchtigkeit unter einen gewissen Schwellenwert
gefallen ist, dann
sagt die Alexa auch wieder Bescheid, dass man die Fenster
wieder schließen kann. Das Ganze
läuft auch übers Handy, da bekommt
man eine Benachrichtigung aufs Handy über Open Hub,
falls man nicht im Rauma sein sollte, um die Alexa
nicht zu hören.
So, nachdem wir die Tür geöffnet haben,
wird das quasi alles einmal
in Gang gesetzt. Das wird erkannt, ob wir geduscht
haben oder nicht mit dem Fenster.
Und dann dauert es ca.
10 Minuten. In den
10 Minuten haben wir noch Zeit uns
fertig zu machen, vielleicht
noch kurz die Ohren zu putzen, die Haare zu kämmen,
uns die Zähne zu putzen.
Und wenn das der Fall ist,
dass wir dann quasi aus dem Raum raus sind,
fängt nach den 10 Minuten an,
der Wischroboter hierher
zu fahren. Wenn wir es jetzt,
wie jetzt im Moment draußen,
richtiges High IQ-Bard, dunkel haben,
dann macht er uns das
Licht vom Spiegel
an, damit der Roboter einfach bis er mal
sehen kann. Und
macht das Licht auch wieder aus, weil der Roboter
fertig ist. Aber funktioniert das gut
genug, dass du auch, na gut, das ist eine
Frage des Schwellenwerts, ob auch bei
offenem Fenster die Luftfeuchtigkeit ausreichend
ansteigt. Nicht, dass im Sommer nicht
gewischt wird, weil du bei offenem Fenster
duschst. Also bei Fenster auf Kipp oder so.
Etwas weniger automatisch als
in dem Clip ist der Sponsor des heutigen Videos
der Marc V1 Ultra. Aber
manchmal braucht man einfach die große Keule, gerade
mit Kindern, Haustieren oder... Ein
Staubsauger. Der steht einfach immer einsatzbereit in seiner Station.
Wasser im Tank... Alter, ich würde im Leben
nicht auf die Idee kommen Ketchup mit dem Staubsauger
aufzusaugen.
Reinigungsmittel im Reinigungsmitteltank.
Einfach greifen und los geht's. Wenn du mal
was eingetrockneteres, hartnäckigeres
wegwischen willst, dann schaltest du einfach den Dampf dazu.
Der ist in wenigen Sekunden bereit.
Und wenn du fertig bist, stellst du ihn in seine Station.
Er reinigt sich mit seinem Triple Self Cleaning
System von alleine. Triple Self
Cleaning.
Du füllst einfach oben frisches Wasser nach und leerst
gelegentlich das Dreckwasser aus, dessen Ergebnis
wirklich nicht schön ist. Auch in Räumen
kann man den Dreck aussteigen.
Und das ermöglichen der Preisgelder für eure Einsenden.
Raphael hat seine smarte Haustüre als Short geschickt.
So, ich zeig euch jetzt, die man nach dem
Einkaufen die Tür öffnet.
Und zwar automatisch.
Smart Lock. Ich mag keine
Smart Locks.
Ich hab da für den Hörmann-Tür
Öffnerschließer irgendwie, wie das heißt,
da gekauft. Das hab ich dann installiert.
Installiert?
Mit dem Switchbot und dem Switchbot-Assensor,
dass du das erkennst.
Boah, was ist das für eine Tür?
Alles bisschen kompliziert gewesen, weil die Tür...
Das ist ja High IQ Tür.
Da sind ja 50 Sensoren an der Tür.
...aufspringen muss.
Und dann hab ich einfach so von einer Klingel,
von einer Fahrradklingel.
Wie viele
Fenster sind so an der Tür?
Die ganze Tür ist voll.
Da darf aber keiner mit Herzschrittmacher zu Besuch kommen,
oder? Keiner irgendwie, weiß ich nicht.
Den Kühlschrank kannst du auch nicht reintragen.
Du bleibst ja einfach im Magnetfeld der Tür hängen.
Federung hab ich da in der Tür eingebaut,
dass die aufspringt.
Und dann der Sensor das erkennt.
Und dann kann ich so mit Romkit
steuern, die Tür halt.
Alter! Das war eine kleine Spielerei.
Ich hab aber so viele Fragen.
Erstmal muss ich das nachvollziehen.
Dein Nuki schließt auf,
wenn du nach Hause kommst.
Und dann drückt diese Fahrradklingelfeder
die Tür auf. So weit kann ich folgen.
Weißt du durch deine zahlreichen Fensterkontakte,
dass die Tür offen ist?
Na, dass die Tür aufspringt,
ist wahrscheinlich, dass er drauf reagieren kann,
dass der eigentliche Türöffner
anfängt die Tür zu öffnen.
Und kannst dem Switchbot-Ding sagen,
dass er sie
oder es auf den Knopf
von dem Hörmann-Tür-schließ-Ding
drückt
und die Tür geschlossen wird.
Das ist nochmal ein Level über meiner normalen
Smartlock-Funktion einfach mit Einkäufen in der Hand
und nach Hause zu kommen.
Ich hab mir extra Kinder angeschafft, damit die hinter mir die Tür
zumachen können, wenn ich die Hände voll habe.
Aber die hat man ja auch nicht immer dabei.
Ja, Chet, extra Stromverbrauch
ist das. Also es ist
eine Illusion zu glauben, dass man mit
Smart Home irgendwie großartig Geld sparen kann.
Man kann potenziell
Geld sparen. Bei Heizkosten
sowas zum Beispiel. Allerdings
bis man, man wird nie
die Anschaffungskosten da
höchstwahrscheinlich zumindest.
Man muss immer die Anschaffungskosten irgendwann wieder einsparen.
Also das glaube ich nicht.
Sinnvoll
ist es halt, wenn es dir
das Leben
einfacher macht. Zum Beispiel,
wenn die Werte von deiner Waage
irgendwo hin übertragen werden, dass du dann schön nachgucken kannst
und jetzt ohne China-Chinesen-Cloud,
dass du schön nachgucken kannst,
wie du abgenommen hast. Ist ja auch
eine motivierende Sache. Oder dass du
auf ein Dashboard gucken kannst
und sehen, ah, bevor ich aus dem Haus
gehe, es sind alle Fenster zu. Oder im Zweifelsfall,
dir das Ding eine Push-
Notification schickt,
wenn du vergessen hast, ein Fenster zuzumachen,
wenn du das Haus verlässt und sowas.
Das sind schon Sachen, die bringen einen gewissen Mehrwert.
Oder auch, dass man sagt,
hey, die Klimaanlage geht schon mal
automatisch an fünf Minuten, bevor ich daheim bin,
wenn es draußen über 30 Grad
ist oder über 35 Grad. Oder wenn
die Innentemperatur über so und so viel ist
und draußen über 35 Grad, gibt es ja
unterschiedlichste
Sachen.
Oder so simple Sachen wie, es geht
ein Licht an,
wenn es nach einer gewissen
Uhrzeit ist und ich die Treppe runterlaufen muss
und solche Geschichten. Kann man schon
sinnvolle Sachen
mitmachen. Die meisten Leute machen
halt unsinnige Sachen, die vielleicht auf den
ersten Blick gut aussehen, wie zum Beispiel
alles mit RGB
ausstatten,
die aber da nichts bringen. Ja,
das braucht unnötig Strom und
hat keinen Sinn, aber man kann schon
sinnvolle Sachen machen.
Die einem auch wirklich täglich was
dass das angenehmer
gestalten.
Und manchmal sind die auch ein bisschen trotzig.
Fluid ja selbst, Solaranlage
ist doch nicht illegal, kannst du machen.
Ist nicht illegal.
Solange du das korrekt machst.
Und solange
du nicht in dieses Problem
mit ans Stromnetz
anschließen, über
Watt und
keinen eigenen Zähler
und was, da gibt es ja zig Auflagen.
Aber wenn du eine eigene Solaranlage aufs
Dach baust, um damit
dein beispielsweise Elektroauto zu laden,
sodass es nicht ins normale Stromnetz geht,
ist überhaupt kein Ding, darfst du machen.
Das ist richtig.
Wenn du es mit dem Stromnetz verbindest,
dann musst du deinem
Netzbetreiber Bescheid sagen, wenn es
über 600 Watt ist, brauchst du glaube ich
einen eigenen Zähler und solche Dinge.
Ich finde gut, was du
aus seiner Tür gemacht hast.
Sie ist auf jeden Fall
automatisierter als
die meisten anderen Türen.
Also die Tür, die sah ja wirklich aus,
die ist ja gespickt mit
Fenstersensoren.
Video geschickt.
Servus, ich bin heute mal draußen
und ich hatte jetzt öfter mal,
ich bin auch mal draußen, aber nicht oft,
das Vergnügen aufzuwachen.
Dann steige ich auf mein Fahrrad, weil ich irgendwo hin muss
und ich habe einen Platten.
Und um da was gegen zu machen, habe ich mir
jetzt solche Drucksensoren besorgt.
Aha.
Die sitzen auf dem Ventil und überwachen ständig den Druck.
Die haben irgendwie Bluetooth und
Ant Plus.
Was ist Ant Plus?
Eigentlich gibt es eine App für, aber ich habe da
in meiner Wohnung einen Raspberry Pi.
Der verbindet sich damit,
liest regelmäßig den Stand aus.
Und wenn das unter einem bestimmten Level fällt,
kriege ich eine ...
Coole Sache, ich frage mich nur, wie lange die Batterien erhalten
in den kleinen Sensoren.
Nachricht per Telegramm, das heißt, dann weiß ich sofort
Bescheid, wenn ich zu wenig
druck. Oder ziehen Sie sich die Energie
irgendwie aus, weil für Solar
ist es zu klein?
Super cool.
Ich mag exotische Sensoren.
Und ich finde gut, dass dein Smartphone
weiß, wie viel Druck du auf dem Schlauch hast.
Ich wäre nie auf die Idee gekommen, das so zu machen.
Aber das funktioniert ja vielleicht auch
als Alarmanlage.
Denn wenn der Druck abfällt,
ne, der wird nicht immer sofort schreien, wenn die Verbindung
weg ist. Na ja gut, dann vergesst das mit der Alarmanlage.
Aber ich bin auf jeden Fall
auch großer Freund der elektrischen
Xiaomi-Pumpe, die du da hattest.
Sollte nach meinem Dafürhalten in keinem
Haushalt fehlen. Ist universell stark,
schick, bezahlbar.
Link findet ihr auch unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Aber ich schweife ab.
Hormatik oder ähnlichen optischen Fenstersensor
für zwei Fenster nutzen.
Ein Sparfuchs-Ding. Ich hoffe, das ist nicht mit
irgendwie hin und her tragen gelöst.
Ja, hallo.
Ich wollte nur kurz einen kleinen
Hardware-Hack zeigen.
Ich habe hier ein Fenster mit
einem Hormatic
Fenstersensor, einem optischen.
Und da ist ja eigentlich nur mal
darum geht zu wissen, ob in einem Zimmer
ein Fenster auf ist. Aber relativ egal
ist welches Fenster das ist.
Wollte ich nur einen Sensor benutzen.
Deswegen gibt es
ein Fenster
innen einen
silbernen Aufkleber. Und bei
der anderen Fenster habe ich mir ein
kleines Dreieck
gedruckt mit 3D.
Coole Idee! Coole Idee!
Feilfert.
Man kann diese Folie auch aufgeklebt hat.
So das praktisch beide.
Coole Idee!
Ist nur was ganz kleines,
aber Simples. So was finde ich
immer cool.
Folien da sein müssen, damit der
Kontakt geschlossen wird. Und das funktioniert bestimmt auch gut.
Ob die geschlossen wird. Und so
ist das Fenster egal, ob man klappt. Das finde ich cool.
Auf welcher Seite. Das ist
immer darauf, dass
ein Fenster geöffnet ist.
Sprich, in dem Moment
eines der beiden Fenster irgendwie klappt.
Hätte man jetzt einen magnetischen Kontakt,
wäre das relativ simpel.
Man könnte einfach hier oben den
Sensor hinmachen in die Mitte. Und hier
was Magnetisches dran und da was
Magnetisches dran. Sei es im Zweifelsfall auch nur mit
Heißkleber.
Und dann wird das funktionieren. Aber das ist
auch eine coole Sache. Finde ich nice.
Geöffnet ist, kriege ich mitgeteilt,
ist offen und kann dann hier nachgucken.
Und damit brauche ich in jedem Raum mit Doppelfenstern
nur noch einen Sensor.
Tja Markus, ich weiß gar nicht so richtig, was ich
sagen soll. Das ist
eine schlaue Sache. In meinen Augen sollten wir
Elon Musk durch dich ersetzen.
Gut, kann eigentlich grundsätzlich
nur besser werden. Aber das ist einfach
eine 200 EQ Aktion.
Ich liebe sowas.
Außer, dass ich den Fenstersensor nicht verbaut habe.
Aber die Art und Weise,
mehr aus dem einen Sensor rauszuholen.
Ganz fantastisch. Und dann haben wir
einen Höhlensensor mit Türkontakt.
Hi Andreas, ich habe eben einen Aufruf gesehen
zu zeigen, was man mit Sensoren machen kann.
Ah, jetzt kommt der Ultraschall-Sensor.
Deswegen wollte ich meinen Einsatz von einem Akara-Sensor zeigen.
Ich sage jetzt darum,
ich habe einen Stehschreibtisch.
Aber ich auch, benutze ich, wie zu selten.
Ich wollte mir meinen einbauen,
der mich daran erinnert,
alle 15 Minuten aufzustehen.
Ich kenne zwar andere YouTuber, ich kaufe mir extra für Laufbänder.
Aber so dekanent wollte ich ja nicht sein.
Nicht zum Erinnern, sondern
zum Nicht-Hinsetzen. Aber ja.
Hier ist das
Laufband.
Das folgt.
Ich habe hier hinter so eine Aluleiste.
Das ist einmal ein Vierkantrohr.
Und da drin steckt ein dünneres Rohr zur Stabilisierung.
Und dann habe ich hier jeweils unten und oben
ist leider schwarz
so Halter.
Hä? Und da dran klebt jetzt
ein Fensterkontakt einfach. Und?
Und dann hier noch ein kleiner Magnet.
Ah!
Verstehe, verstehe.
Das ist ja aufs Eisen. Genau.
Das siehst du, wenn der Fensterkontakt
vorbeifährt.
Ja.
Fährt er irgendwann da sonst vorbei.
Hm.
Dann verfährt auf halbem Weg
halt der Sensor an. Man geht vorbei.
Gute Idee. Und danach
fällt mir das Schreibtisch auf den Kopf.
Nee. Und öffnet sich
danach wieder. Und diesen
Wechsel kann man halt einfach in Home Assistant zum Beispiel
auswerten. Noch eine kleine Ergänzung.
Diese Akara-Dinger sind eigentlich
ein Wunder, Kinder.
Man kann nämlich einfach mal die Platinen aus dem
Gehäuse entfernen. Da was dranlöten.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon auf Reddit gesehen.
Da gibt es ein paar Bauanleitungen für
spezielle Use Cases.
Diese zwei kleinen
Öffnungen hier.
Da sind es eigentlich zwei so hohe
Bohrungen.
Ganz normale Dupontstecker einstecken.
Muss man nicht mal löten. Und das dann
beliebe ich öffnen und schließe. Man kann zum Beispiel
hier mit so einem
Vorplatine nehmen und dann so einen
Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor.
Hier ist jetzt ein Bild.
Auswerten zu können. Das heißt, da kann man
quasi sämtliche
Sensoren irgendwie anschließen.
Ob das Schalter, Taster,
Endlagengeber oder was auch immer sind.
Das erklärt auf jeden Fall,
warum ihr so viele
Akara-Sensoren über meine Links kauft.
Sehr schöne Automation auf jeden Fall an deinem Schreibtisch.
Also auch ein ausgefeiltes System.
Ich wäre im Leben nie drauf gekommen, das mit einem Fenster
Kontakt zu lösen. Aber gut.
Fabian auch nicht. Darum hat er ein Video geschickt mit
Ultraschall-Sensor am Schreibtisch.
Heute mein 3D gedrucktes
Gehäuse mit
Ultraschall-Sensor und Vemus
D1 ESP-Chip.
Damit messe ich, wie häufig
mein Stehschreibtisch in der oberen
Position ist und wie lange...
Also jetzt habe ich nicht zugehört.
Ja, ist ein Ultraschall-Sensor.
Hatte ich doch recht.
Ich am Schreibtisch sitze. Kombiniert wird das
Ganze dann im AIO. Also Chet, doch
kein Cock-Sender.
Sondern
ein Abstandsmesser.
Mess-Steckdose am Bildschirm, damit ich auch weiß,
wann ich dann am Tisch bin.
Und ergibt am Ende dann ein
ganz nettes Diagramm. Das hätte ich ja gerne
gesehen, also das Diagramm. Aber man weiß ja nie,
ob dein Chef vielleicht zuschaut. Und wenn wir jetzt hier
genau sehen, wann du am
Schreibtisch gestanden und gesessen hast,
da
wäre ich auch vorsichtig. Sehr schön auf jeden Fall.
Gute Idee.
Das könnte ich vielleicht auch mal, dass ich das zusammenbringe.
Position des Schreibtisches,
meines Walking Pads und das
alles irgendwie in Grafana auswerten.
Vielleicht sogar mit meinen eigenen
Health-Daten aus dem iPhone.
Mit Schrittzahl und
Gewicht oder so. Es gibt so viele
Projekte. Danke auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe mir überlegt, die Zuschauerautomation
dieses Jahr ein bisschen stärker
thematisch zu gruppieren. Darum kann es sein,
dass eure Einsendungen vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen
warten müssen. Dieses Mal
fehlten mir ein paar Sensoren. Darum habe ich einen Aufruf gemacht
und jetzt habe ich so viele bekommen, dass
ich eigentlich schon fast einen zweiten Teil voll habe.
Aber mit Automation
rund im Haustier habt ihr auf jeden Fall
immer gute Karten ins Video zu kommen.
Diese sind in der Regel recht knapp.
Und wir können uns ja vielleicht einfach mal
auch für die kommenden Folgen ein paar
Themen, Schwerpunkte überlegen. Wenn ihr Vorschläge habt,
schreibt die gerne in die Kommentare.
Und dann schauen wir, was weiß ich,
eure Steuermöglichkeiten oder eure
Dashboards oder so mal an.
Egal, was ihr habt, schickt es gerne unter
zeug.coolslash.zeigen und dann würde ich
sagen, bis zum nächsten Mal. Danke fürs Zuschauen.
Danke an alle Einsender.
Bis zum nächsten Mal habe ich schon gesagt.
Tschüss.
Ja, da könnte man vielleicht auch was in der
Richtung bauen.
Aber jetzt wird erstmal mein
Katzenbrunnen smart gemacht.
Ich muss noch gucken, wie ich das Ding gescheit
ins WLAN bekomme.
Und
das in den
Homesystem integriert krieg.
NodeMCU
so einfach ist es in dem Fall nicht.
Das muss wahrscheinlich einmalig
in der offiziellen App angemeldet werden.
Ja, mal gucken.
So, was können wir uns noch zeigen?
Building a low power all in one
Server.
So viel verdiene ich als Informatiker.
Fahr Lehrer für
LKW und Panzer.
Oh nee, das kann ich mir jetzt
nicht geben. Zu viel, zu viel
Militärdrill.
Twitter...
Was ich mir denn jetzt an?
Low Power Server, das ist wahrscheinlich
wieder nur irgendein Müll, oder? Wir skippen
da mal kurz drüber. Hardware Specs.
Okay, was ist drinne?
I5
Okay, das ist so eine ganz
stinknormale Box. Da ist überhaupt nichts
besonderes dran.
Gar kein so großer Unterschied zu der
Box, die ich erst letztens bei mir auf dem Channel
gezeigt habe. Ich meine, das war ein anderer Ansatz.
Bei mir war das ja quasi mit...
Hallo Leute.
Meine Box war ja quasi integriert.
Mit allem, aber von der Größe
und so macht es ja gar keinen großen...
Nee, das müssen wir uns, das müssen wir uns
nicht angucken.
Hypervisor. Ach,
musste jetzt noch einen vierten Kubernetes-Cluster
daheim drauf aufbauen.
Okay, ist natürlich praktisch, dass das Ding
6 Gigabit...
Vermute mal Gigabit.
Das hat das Gigabit.
Oder das 2,5
Gigabit
Network.
Sieht man nicht.
Na gut.
Okay, interessiert mich nicht. Brauch man nicht.
Muss man nicht gucken.
Wo bloß? Wann machen wir mal wieder...
Oh ja, wird Zeit.
Erst recht, wird mal wieder Zeit.
Abgerei, der eine,
wo mich deine Meinung interessiert,
mit DevOps-Engineer Windows. Klingt erst mal
cringe. Aber hatte dort schon
ein Gespräch mit... Ja, schick. Wir können uns
jetzt angucken, wenn du willst.
Wie machst du das
mit deinem Arbeitsplatz zu Hause und deinem
Homeoffice-Rechner? Arbeitest du mit Switches oder hast
du zwei Arbeitsplätze? Also aktuell
habe ich ein Notebook
von der Arbeit, das benutze ich, das schließe ich
per
HDMI-Kabel
an den zweiten Monitoren.
Ich habe dir übrigens
auf Facebook Messenger
eine Nachricht geschrieben.
Facebook?
Facebook habe ich seit 5 Jahren oder so nicht mehr
offen gehabt.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal, ob ich ob das Login habe
für Facebook noch.
Ja, wenn schon über
StudiVZ.
Beste.
So.
Das hier, Stellenangebot,
DevOps-Engineer. Okay, zeig mal.
Zeig mal. Ja, komm, wir akzeptieren, alles
gut ist.
DevOps-Engineer Schwerpunkt
Windows.
Was ist das hier?
Was ist das?
DevOps-Engineer Schwerpunkt
Windows. Also die Kombination
muss ich ja, muss ich ja zugeben.
Man kann auf der Seite nicht zoomen.
Warum kann man auf der Seite nicht zoomen?
Hä?
Die haben irgendwie ausgestellt,
dass man zoomen kann auf der Seite.
Was ist das denn?
Control funktioniert nicht.
Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass man das überschreiben kann, dass man auf Seiten
zoomen kann.
Ich kann nicht zoomen. Control
Mausrad geht normalerweise. Auf anderen Seiten geht
es auch, aber da nicht
irgendwas haben sie da komisches gemacht.
DevOps-Engineer GN.
Für was, was, was, was
soll GN bedeuten?
Ach, Gender Neutral.
Alter.
Okay, das ist die
moderne Reform von MWD.
Schwerpunkt Windows. Ab
sofort Vollzeitstandort Karlsruhe
Remote.
Okay, also
was, was haben sie denn hier am Start?
Das erwartet, erwartet dich.
Du bist erst der Ansprechpartner.
Alter, man kann es irgendwie auch übertreiben,
oder?
Du bist erst der
Ansprechpartner, gender neutral
und mitverantwortlich
für den Continuous Delivery Prozess
unserer Softwareprodukte
von der Konzeption bis zur
Implementierung von automatischen
Deployments. Gut, das klingt so nach
einer klassischen DevOps-Geschichte.
Du analysierst
die Anforderungen unserer Kunden- und
Support-Teams und leitest daraus die
technische Umsetzung. Ja, okay.
Du unterstützt und berätst unsere
Entwicklerteams, sowie unsere
Support-Teams in allen Fragen zum Deployment
und leitest die Kolleginnen
ach, hier ist nicht gender neutral,
bezüglich der verwenden Werkzeuge. Okay,
ja, klingt auch irgendwie sinnig,
wenn die Fragen haben zu irgendwelchen
Pipelines, Tools und sonst was, ja,
warum nicht?
Was hältst du generell vom Gendern?
Ich halte das für eine der überflüssigsten
Diskussionen überhaupt. Warum darüber
so viel diskutiert wird, ist ganz klar.
Das ist ein bisschen, kennt ihr
diese Story von Management-Meetings,
wo über komplizierte Sachen nicht
geredet wird, aber über die Farbe vom Fahrrad.
Sowas ist das, glaube ich,
auch nur so auf die gesamte
Gesellschaft übertragen.
Jeder hat irgendeine Meinung dazu, jeder
kann dazu irgendwas sagen, das ist schön
greifbar, es ist schön easy für jeden.
Und es gibt wenige, die
so sagen, ja,
eigentlich noch nie Gedanken, eigentlich mir
egal. Jeder kann irgendwie was zu sagen,
jeder will irgendwie was dazu sagen, aber an
sich ist es, glaube ich, eines der unsinnigsten,
überflüssigsten Diskussionen, die es gibt.
So, du unterstützt und berätst
unsere Entwicklerteams, sowie unsere
Supportteams, sag mal gerade. Du
entwickelst neues und bestehende Automatisierungstooling
auf Basis von PowerShell.
Okay, hey, ich meine, das ist Schwerpunkt
Windows, da dürfen die mit sowas wie PowerShell
anfangen.
Du bewertest Trends und Technologien,
identifizierst zukunftsfähige
Innovationsthemen.
Damit kann ja alles
irgendwie gemeint sein, aber gut, dass
wir uns mal reingeschrieben haben. Du unterstützt den Third Level
Support für alle Themen
rund ums Deployment, ja.
Ich
müsste man eigentlich nicht extra schreiben, das ist ja
mehr oder weniger hier oben schon mit
drinne. Okay, du
bringst mit.
PowerShell gibt es für Linux, ja.
Es gibt sogar Microsoft SQL Server für
Linux, habe ich gehört. Aber ob das jemand
freiwillig benutzt,
man weiß es nicht.
Das
bringst du mit.
Erfolgreich abgeschlossenes
IT-affines Studium
im Bereich der Informatik oder
eine erfolgreiche, ja, das ist auch relativ standard,
aktuelles Know-how in den
IT-Feldern, Application,
Lifecycle-Management-Prozesse
sowie Konfigurations- und
Change-Management-Systeme. Okay,
Vertieftige in PowerShell, Windows.
Idealerweise Erfahrung, Build,
Deployment, Paketierungsprozesse,
Tools wie Nuke. Oh, da wird dort
Netzzeug gemacht.
Alles klar, das verwendet jemand im Businessumfeld,
wusste ich gar nicht.
Nexus, Java, Zeug, Jenkins.
Okay, Octopus
Deploy, habe ich noch nie verwendet, habe ich mal gelesen,
kein Plan von.
Wünschen zu erzielen Kenntnis im Datenbanken,
methodisch und strukturiert, okay, bla,
bla, bla, Hands-on-Mentalität
sowie Freude an der Vernetzung in verschiedenen Teams.
Das heißt, man schwätzt gerne mit anderen Leuten,
da würde ich schon wieder rausfallen.
Man könnte das noch ein bisschen
mehr
Buzzword-mäßig machen.
Du verfolgst einen,
okay, wie könnte man das schreiben?
Du verfolgst einen
Hands-on-Holistic-Approach.
So wie Freude
an der Vernetzung.
Holistic ist ein
beliebtes Wort
aktuell, damit ist
ganzheitlich gemeint.
Aber Holistic klingt viel geiler, oder?
Ganzheitlich
ist langweilig, aber Holistic klingt schon
cool.
Das wird auch gerne zur Zeit geschrieben.
Holistic Approach.
Okay.
Wie findest du,
es geduzt zu werden? Das ist mir lieber
als umgedreht. Gute
Deutschkenntnis sowie Englisch, okay, alles klar.
Unsere Mitarbeiter, wir wollen
betriebliche Krankenversicherung.
Okay.
Betriebliche Unfallversicherung.
Shopping-Angebote.
Ihr mit Shopping
gut habt, 30 Tage, okay.
Eine große Portion, okay,
bla, bla, bla, bla.
Tja.
Klingt okay.
Also, ich muss sagen, klingt jetzt nicht
herausgradend, klingt jetzt aber auch
zumindest nicht super, super mies.
Also, es ist auf jeden Fall besser
geschrieben, wie die Stellen anzeigen,
wie die Anzeigen.
Was für ein Unfall man haben kann.
Du kannst aufs Maul fallen, auf dem Heimweg
zum Beispiel. Dich kann jemand anfahren
auf dem Heimweg oder auf dem Weg zur Arbeit.
Also, es gibt ja schon
Möglichkeiten, dass du keinen Einfluss drauf.
Du fällst vom Fahrrad auf dem
Weg zur Arbeit, ja.
Hervorragendes Arbeitsklima.
Geprägt von Anerkennung und Wertschätzung.
Gut, ich glaube Theyen sogar,
dass sie das so meinen, wie sie schreiben.
Ob das wirklich so ist, können sie ja selbst
immer recht schwer beurteilen.
Regelmäßig. Das wäre für mich,
wisst ihr, viele Unternehmen
verkaufen das als Vorteil.
Für mich ist das ehrlich gesagt eher ein
Nachteil. Ich mag
keine Firmen und auch keine
Team-Events. Ich arbeite mit
den Leuten. Ich finde es wichtig, dass man sich mit den Leuten
gut versteht. Irgendwie großartig
dicke sein mit denen außerhalb der
Arbeit muss ich nicht.
Und dann wenn. Dann nur mit den Leuten,
wo ich mir das aussuche und nicht
von der Firma bestimmt.
Aber da stärkt doch den Zusammenhalt.
Mir geht es vor allem auf den Sack. Für mich stärkt
den Zusammenhalt am besten, wenn man auf der
Arbeit gute Sachen hinbekommt zusammen.
Ob ich mit den Leuten
irgendwie mal Kegel spielen gehe,
juckt mich nicht.
Bist du interessiert? Ich nicht, aber
anscheinend. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wer es war, aber
ja, macht keinen schlechten
Eindruck. Also wenn du mit denen schon Gespräche
geführt hast und dir das gefällt, ist doch nice.
Das klingt alles in allem schon ganz
sinnvoll. Es macht auch Sinn, dass es Windows
Schwerpunkt ist, wenn ich hier Powershell lese.
Rest ist schon
ein bisschen 0815, kann man jetzt wenig
dazu sagen.
Aber klingt nicht schlecht oder so.
Du wartest auf die Rückmeldung, ja.
Ja, das ist erlaubt mit
man muss irgendwie doch Zeiterfassung machen,
aber man kann das nachträglich auch eintragen
und sowas. Gibt es Möglichkeiten.
Hab ich schon vollgeplant.
Wo bloß? Ja, so muss es sein.
Anzeige ist raus.
Ja.
Es kommt drauf an.
Es gibt ja auch Leute, die
sind weniger da, als sie müssten.
Für die ist es dann schlecht mit Zeiterfassung.
Außerdem muss man ehrlich gesagt sagen,
wenn nach
Arbeit bezahlt wird und nicht nach
Arbeitszeit,
dann muss das gar nicht mal so ein großer Vorteil sein.
Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sagt,
hey, du musst diese drei Tickets, ist immer
übertrieben gesagt, ja, du musst diese drei Tickets die
Woche schaffen, Rest ist uns egal.
Und du schaffst das in 35 Stunden als
statt in 40. Warum
solltest du noch 5 Stunden länger rumgammeln müssen?
Also, ja, ist
je nachdem
mal so, mal so gut. Kann man
glaube ich nicht pauschal sagen.
Team Event erstmal Artstilungsinstallation.
Das wäre ein Team Event, da würde ich sogar mitmachen.
Ich bin eh für gesetzliche
4-Tage-Woche.
Ist die Frage, wie die 4-Tage-Woche umgesetzt wird.
Wenn die 4-Tage-Woche umgesetzt wird,
du musst 10 Stunden am Tag arbeiten, um wieder
auf 40 zu kommen,
dann ist das sicherlich für manche Branchen
schwer
denkbar, gerade
dort, wo
körperlich gearbeitet wird.
Wobei die ja oftmals eh schon
auf der Baustelle oder so länger arbeiten.
Ansonsten müsste es
dann eher,
ansonsten müsste es dann eher weniger
Arbeitszeit sein fürs gleiche Geld.
Was im Endeffekt ja nicht,
was im Endeffekt ja eine Gehaltserhöhung
bedeutet.
Wenn man sich mal genau überlegt. Also wenn du jetzt
einen Tag weniger arbeiten musst,
also 20% weniger arbeiten
und du gleich Geld bekommst, ist das im Endeffekt eine
Gehaltserhöhung um 20%.
Mr. Moo geben.
Danke schon für den Sub.
Ja, genau.
Du hast aber auch wieder
Leute, die dann schlicht und klar ihre Jobs verlieren
und nicht wissen, was sie machen sollen.
Ist immer zweischneidiges Schwert.
Es wird eh
jetzt schon und auch in Zukunft
noch vermehrt auf uns zukommen,
dass es ganze
Branchen, oder was Branchen ist übertrieben,
ganze, ganze Berufsgruppen gibt,
die jetzt die letzte
Generation macht und dann auch
ganz, ganz viele
Berufsgruppen haben.
Die jetzt die letzte Generation macht
und danach nicht mehr.
Oder eben ausgedünnt wird.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich mir überlege,
in irgendeiner Produktion, wo halt Leute am Fließband
gestanden haben, da stehen halt in Zukunft,
jetzt ja auch schon, was heißt in Zukunft,
hört sich so an, als dauert das noch 20 Jahre, ist ja jetzt
auch schon so, da hast du halt anstatt 20
Leute da stehen, da noch 2-3
Roboterarme und halt
3 Techniker, die du zusätzlich
brauchst, die sich um diese
Geschichten kümmern.
Es wird wahrscheinlich nicht so sein,
dass in der gleichen
Menge, wie auf der einen Seite Arbeit
wegfällt, im Technikbereich
mehr entsteht, zumal
man ja auch nicht jeden technische Berufe
machen lassen kann. Also du kannst jetzt zum Beispiel
nicht sagen, hey guck mal, wir brauchen bald keine
Bergarbeiter mehr, die schulen wir jetzt
alle zum Fachinformatiker um. Ausnahmen
bestätigen die Regel, es gibt bestimmt
durchaus einige Bergarbeiter, die sehr gute
Fachinformatiker abgeben würden, aber
in der Breite kann man das sicherlich nicht
transferieren. Umgedreht
ja auch nicht. Ich glaube
kaum, dass die meisten Fachinformatiker gute
Bergarbeiter wären.
Das wäre tatsächlich das Beste.
Wenn diese
blöde
40-Stunden-Woche oder 38-
oder 5-Tage-Woche generell abgeschafft wird,
da sagt aber die Industrie
dazu, oder zumindest die Arbeitgeberseite
sagt dazu, ja, aber Fachkräftemangel.
Wir finden doch gar keine
Leute und die Arbeit wird auch nicht weniger, also
müssen die Leute eher mehr arbeiten für das gleiche
Geld.
Die Schweiz könnte auch einfach weniger
machen, warum sollten andere mehr machen,
damit man aufs gleiche kommt, macht doch ihr eher lieber
weniger. Außerdem in der Schweiz
verdient man eh viel mehr Kohle.
Dafür bezahlt man auch mehr in der
Schweiz.
Aber die Reichen
werden reicher. Da ist die
einfachste Gegenmaßnahme, einfach
nicht arm sein.
Dann hat man keine Probleme.
Just
Geld haben.
Vorher.
Leute, ich habe Hunger.
Es ist gleich 12 Uhr.
Ein Video können wir uns
noch angucken. Was gucken wir uns jetzt noch an?
Was haben wir denn zu bieten noch?
So viel verdiene ich als Informatiker mit 28.
Okay.
Fahrlehrer für LKW und Panzer.
Komm, wir gucken uns an, wie vieler als Informatiker
mit 28 verdienen.
Ich habe schon ab und zu ein paar Videos von ihm
geguckt. Ich glaube,
das einzige an das ich mich erinnern kann,
gerade so aus dem Stegreif, ist das,
wo er erzählt hat, dass er
überwacht wurde.
Anderes Video, please.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich fand die Videos, die ich von ihm gesehen habe,
gar nicht so schlecht. Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
dass er ein Video gemacht hat, wo er erzählt hat,
dass er von
Facebook
überwacht wurde.
Und dass Facebook Probleme hat.
Oder Instagram war er, glaube ich.
Dass er
irgendwie gekündigt hat,
weil die ihm gesagt haben,
er darf keinen YouTuber machen.
Irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Und was ich mich bei seinen Videos
immer gefragt habe, die ich bisher gesehen habe,
das weiß ich noch, ist immer so ein Gedanken,
den ich im Hinterkopf hatte, ist,
er kommt zwar aus der IT,
aber er wirkt auf mich
ein bisschen mehr wie so ein
Marketing-Social-Typ.
Schwer zu beschreiben.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie viel
ITler und wie viel Marketing-Social-Typer
er ist.
Er wirkt wie ein BWL-Stonk-Typ.
Na ganz so krass, würde ich nicht sagen.
Er wirkt schon ein bisschen so
Marketing-Social-BWL
mäßig.
Aber ich glaube,
Informatik hat er an irgendeiner
super krassen Uni studiert.
Also zumindest so
theoretischen Background
hat er sicherlich.
Der schaut sich immer
Kraftfahrer-Dashboards an.
Genau. Na gut, wenn er sagt,
das Video ist langweilig, was können wir
sonst noch angucken? Fahrlehrer für LKW
und Panzer.
Das Gehalt als Soldat
bei der Bundeswehr lohnt sich das.
Also allein schon, wenn ich bei der Bundeswehr arbeiten
müsste, hätte ich da keinen Bock drauf.
Und wahrscheinlich ist das Gehalt
ähnlich schlecht, wie wenn man sich anguckt,
was irgendwelche MTA bieten
für IT-Jobs. Das ist ja
unterirdisch.
Okay, lasst mal gucken.
Auf geht's.
Es wird
Zeit.
Wenn auch nicht gekommen.
Mein Gehalt
ist in einem Bereich,
was ich mir als
18-Jährige niemals hätte vorstellen
können. Sie beiden sind jetzt
zum Fahren dran.
Viele verkrampfen da natürlich.
Ist ja klar, das erste Mal durch München.
Es gibt Auslandseinsätze, da kann man nicht
einfach mal so schnell eine ADAC rufen.
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Wenn man dem Panzer stecken geblieben ist,
irgendwo in der Wüste, ist mit Abschläppen
schwierig.
Das wird jetzt spannend.
Außer man ist in Battlefield 2042,
da machst du ein bisschen C4 drunter
und fliegst wieder zurück in die Base.
Hi, ich bin die Manu, ich bin 40 Jahre alt
und ihr dürft mich heute begleiten
bei meinem Tag als Fahrlehrerin bei der
Bundeswehr. Wir gehen jetzt
zur Ausbildungshalle, nehmen die Fahrschüler
natürlich mit und machen erstmal
technischen Dienst vor der Benutzung.
Ich habe nämlich gestern tatsächlich
ein, zwei Fehler eingebaut
und da bin ich gespannt, ob die das heute
finden.
Es sind Soldaten
und tatsächlich Bundeswehrfeuerwehr
und zivile Angestellte der Bundeswehr,
die zu uns auf den Lehrgang kommen.
Die haben CE-Führerschein schon im Zivilen.
Die kommen jetzt hierher, um eine Einweisung
und Überprüfung durchzuführen, damit sie
einfach diese militärischen Bestimmungen kennen.
Ich mache erstmal das Licht an,
gucke, ob meine eingebauten
Fehler noch da sind, wie zum Beispiel
so eine Trittleiter, dass die wirklich
geschlossen ist, dass wir nicht so rausfahren.
Die muss wirklich geschlossen und
eingerastet sein, dass es nicht rausfährt.
Da gibt es direkt Anschiss, wenn das
nicht gemacht wird. Gibt es bestimmt
auch so ein offizielles Prüfungsprotokoll,
wo du dich dran halten musst und wenn
du das nicht machst, dann ist
schlecht.
Ich glaube, es wird eher etwas schwieriger,
wenn es darum geht,
so Kleinigkeiten zu überprüfen.
Was wir hier schon sehen,
die Leiter ist nicht gesichert.
Diese Sicherung
muss natürlich auf die Leiter zeigen.
Das werden wir jetzt mal lösen,
um zu schauen,
ob das denn mein
Lehrgangsteil immer noch auffällt.
Die Fallsicherung sollte natürlich unten sein.
Falls die
der Hebel nicht eingerastet ist,
der Hebel, der muss zu sein.
Der muss zu uns zeigen.
Dass das Stützbein nicht nach außen fallen kann.
Guck mal, der Typ da hinten. Habt ihr gesehen?
Der hat schon gespeckt.
Der muss zu sein.
Der muss zu uns zeigen.
Der cheated.
Der hat schon geguckt, wo die Fehler sind.
Um dann nachher
zufälligerweise alles finden zu
können.
Oh, da wird aufgenommen.
Nach außen fallen kann.
Das muss ihnen natürlich auch
auffallen, den Kameraden.
Wunderbar, holen wir sie rein.
Gruppe Frau-Hauptfeldwebel.
Sie gehen jetzt rein, legen ihre Rucksäcke sauber ab,
dass keiner drüber stolpern kann.
Denken Sie an die Sicherheitsbestimmungen
und Papiere, wie wir es gesagt haben,
Schlüssel immer Mann.
Dann führen Sie einfach den technischen Dienst
vor der Benutzung durch, wie wir es gestern durchgeführt haben.
Ein Fehler wurde schon gefunden.
Mit dem Tritt.
Unser Hebel wurde gefunden.
Unsere Freisicherung wurde gefunden.
Jetzt muss man nach hinten gehen.
Er hat es gefunden.
Das waren jetzt alle.
Das ging ja wie beim Boxenstopp.
Das ging ja fix.
Das ist ein LKW.
Normalerweise macht es doch
wahrscheinlich eine oder zwei.
Ohne Ende.
Sehr gut, alle Fehler, die ich eingebaut habe,
haben Sie gefunden.
Ich mache das nicht, um Sie zu ärgern,
dass Sie einfach sensibilisiert sind,
dass Sie vor jeder Fahrt einmal rucken,
dass da alles passt und nichts rausfallen kann.
Da haben Sie super gemacht für den ersten Tag.
Top.
Und jetzt gehen wir heim, easy.
Dann brauchen wir einen Freiwilligen, der fährt,
den Anhänger mit dem LKW verbinden
und das Verbindende gemeinsam durchführen.
Die haben ja einen CI-Führerschein.
Nichtsdestotrotz sind sie schon etwas aufgeregt.
Viele haben Angst davor,
das erste Mal durch München zu fahren.
Sie beiden sind jetzt zum Fahren dran.
Sie müssen nicht nervös sein.
Ich bin bei Ihnen. Wir gucken uns das an.
Er ist nervös, weil sie dabei ist.
Nicht umgedreht.
Dass Sie sich da
wohlfühlen.
Dann kriegen wir das hin.
Wenn der Prüfernebel dir sitzt,
bist du noch nicht entspannt,
sondern eher aufgeregt, weil er da ist.
Fahrlehrer bei der Bundeswehr zu machen,
der nicht immer einfach für mich war.
Ich konnte das nicht so schnell lernen,
wie vielleicht jemand, der
Abitur gemacht hat. Ich komme aus einer Gastarbeiterfamilie.
Ist das wichtig, dafür
Abitur zu haben? Ich glaube nicht.
Aufgrund dessen wurde ich auch häufig gemobbt.
In jungen Jahren hatte ich immer das Gefühl,
dass ich gut genug bin. Ich habe ja
Friseurin gelernt. Ich habe meinen Hauptschulabschluss
fertig gemacht.
Ich habe mich dann jahrelang
über Wasser gehalten.
Ich war dann auch 5 Jahre lang an einer Tankstelle tätig.
Ich habe nur 900 Euro verdient.
Und das mit Schichteln.
Frühschicht, Nachtschicht,
abends alleine zusperren.
Und
an dieser Tankstelle hatte ich dann
eine Begegnung mit einem Wehrdienstberater,
der häufig bei mir zum Tanken gekommen ist.
Der hat sie quasi rekrutiert.
Also falls ihr das anschaut, vielen lieben
Dank. Er hat mein Leben verändert.
Und
der hat mich dann
angesprochen, hat er gesagt,
würdest du dich nicht dafür interessieren, Soldat
zu werden?
Wenn mich jemand ansprechen würde, würdest du dich nicht dafür
interessieren, Soldat zu werden?
Das einzige, was ich darauf antworten könnte,
ist tatsächlich...
Oh Gott!
Oh Gott, bitte nicht!
Also im Leben nicht.
Gibt's noch Fragen? Dann
auf geht's.
Let's go.
Rush B.
Ich möchte einfach gucken, wie reagiert der Fahrschüler?
Wie kommt er mit seiner Nervosität klar?
Denn es ist auch für mich wichtig
zu sehen, okay, wie funktioniert
er denn, wenn er nervös ist?
Weil so eine ähnliche Situation haben wir dann,
wenn der Prüfer drin sitzt.
Dann einmal die Meldung.
Frau Hauptwehrwebel,
fahrtechnische Vorbereitung abgeschlossen, Sicherheit
im und am Fahrzeug hergestellt.
Das muss ganz korrekt sein, da wird bestimmt
Wert drauf gelegt.
Ja, also bei mir gab es noch
Wehrpflicht, als ich das machen
musste, da gab es noch Wehrpflicht.
Ich habe aber keinen
Wehrdienst gemacht, sondern ich habe
Zivildienst gemacht, und zwar in einer behinderten
Werkstatt. Und im Nachhinein
muss ich sagen,
es war gar nicht schlecht, das zu machen.
Da kommt man mal mit Leuten
in Kontakt, wo man normalerweise,
und ihr wisst, ich habe es mit zwischenmenschlichen Sachen
nicht so, aber das war tatsächlich was
Besonderes. Also man hat erstmal übelste
Berührungsängste,
kommt dann aber relativ schnell dahinter,
wie individuell da auch die Leute sind.
Also es ist, es war mal
wirklich interessante Erfahrung,
es ist allerdings nichts,
was ich jetzt
beruflich hätte machen wollen.
Das hat mich mal wieder, das hat mich, wie gesagt,
ich sagte, es war eine interessante Sache, das mal
gesehen zu haben, das mal gemacht zu haben, aber es
hat mich weiterhin darin bestärkt, ich will definitiv
nichts mit Menschen und Soziales machen.
Nach vorne schauen, da kommt eine
Bushaltestelle und da kommt noch
in weiter Ferien ein ganz interessantes
Verkehrszeichen mit
einem roten Rand. Ey, du streamst doch auf
Twitch? Ne, wie kommst du da drauf?
Eine Geschwindigkeitsbeschränkung
mit einem Zusatzzeichen.
Das war ja eine
30er-Zone mit
vielen parkenden Fahrzeugen.
Da kann man sehr gut die Vorausschau üben.
Das heißt, wenn das Hindernis
mit den parkenden Fahrzeugen auf einen zukommt
mit dem LKW, dass man ganz weit nach vorne guckt.
Snapchat ist das, dachte ich.
Kommt da keiner. Yep.
Und wenn da keiner
kommt, dann entscheiden wir uns natürlich reinzufahren.
Das klingt
sinnvoll. Wenn frei ist, fährt man durch.
Ja. Okay.
Ja. So, jetzt können wir uns natürlich
nicht mehr wegzaubern.
Hier, genau, kommt noch ein
Regenverkehr. Nicht ganz so weit nach rechts.
Bisschen Ruhe reinbringen und gleich wieder
blinkern.
Funktioniert. Merkt man gar nicht, dass sie
ein Jahr nicht mehr gefahren sind.
Da freut er sich.
So, beide natürlich Hände am Lenkrad. So 10 und 14 Uhr.
Oh nein.
Ein Auto.
Aber da kommen wir nicht vorbei. Das wird jetzt spannend.
Normalerweise kann man schon mal damit
rechnen, dass man vielleicht sogar
angehubt wird. Verbotene Zeichen
mit den Händen, kennt man ja.
Das heißt, entweder
muss derjenige dann rückwärts fahren
oder sich... Einfach, einfach über die Wiese.
Easy.
Wenn man auf die Vorausschau anderer
Verkehrsteilnehmer achten muss, dann hat man meistens
Probleme.
Er sollte vielleicht mal links hinplinken
erstmal, dass der Typ weiß, dass er links
lang will, oder?
Mit unserem 18 Meter langen
Zug wären wir da nicht reingekommen.
Wir hätten da zwar reinfahren
können, aber entweder der Anhänger
oder die Front vom LKW wäre
dann eh in der Fahrbahn reingeragt. Also der
hätte dann keinen Platz gehabt.
Genau, kurz warten, schauen, was die Kameraden
machen.
Hat sich fürs Rückwärtsfahren entschieden.
Da ist es dann wichtig, dass man
Ruhe bewahrt. Erst, dass wir dann etwas näher
dran waren, wurde dann auch
demjenigen bewusst, dass wir da nicht so
ganz reinpassen.
Manchmal brauchen natürlich die anderen
Verkehrsteilnehmer viel Geduld mit uns.
Der hat es natürlich recht
nett gemacht. Wir bedanken uns
immer sehr freundlich und lächeln.
Dann freuen sich die normalerweise
auch.
Die sind froh, dass er endlich vorbei ist.
Dass die in den grünen Streifen reinfahren, aber okay.
Oh Gott, darf ich das jetzt sagen?
Natürlich hatte ich tatsächlich schon mal
ein Spiegel auf dem Gewissen. Es kann schon mal vorkommen.
Sie machen natürlich langsamer.
Wirklich langsamer machen.
Begrüßen wir die Kameraden
freundlich.
Macht einen entspannten Eindruck.
Die erste Ausbildungsfahrt,
was mir gut gefallen hat, die Spiegelbeobachtung.
Ich war auch erstaunt darüber,
dass er so ruhig gewirkt hat und er hat das
wirklich grandios
hinbekommen. Wie haben Sie sich
gefühlt? Super.
Endlich wieder LKW fahren.
Dann würde ich sagen, Schlüssel ziehen wir einmal ab.
Machen wir ein kurzes Päuschen,
damit sie ein bisschen zur Ruhe kommen.
Dann machen wir auch
weiter mit den Kunstveraufgaben.
Ich will mir anschauen, ob das
klappt mit dem Rückwärtsfahren im Anhängen.
Das ist tatsächlich so ein bisschen
das Schwierigste häufig. Ich bin Soldat
auf Zeit. Und wie viel kommt darum? Wenn ich Glück habe,
werde ich als Berufssoldat übernommen.
Man muss tatsächlich, wenn man Soldat auf Zeit ist,
sich schon wieder auf das zivile Leben
vorbereiten. Das heißt,
man muss verschiedene Vorsorge...
Jetzt mal blöde Frage.
Gibt es auch Soldaten nicht auf Zeit?
Nee, oder?
Man kann es ja schlecht bis zur Rente machen.
...dass man dann wieder auch im zivilen Bereich
wieder... So nach dem Motto,
der Panzer muss rausgefahren werden. Oh, ich kann heute
so schlecht laufen, Alter.
Berufssoldaten,
aber das doch auch auf Zeit?
Oder nicht?
Das ist doch nicht bis zur Rente,
oder?
Ernsthaft? Okay, das ist wahr, habe ich keine Ahnung von.
...einschränkungen übernommen werden. Okay, wie viel gab es jetzt?
Dann muss man dann wieder auch im zivilen
Bereich wieder ohne Einschränkungen
übernommen werden. So, wir machen jetzt
Grundveraufgaben. Die erste Grundveraufgabe,
die wir durchgeführt haben, ist ja dieses
Rückwärtsgerade an einer Rampe zum B
und Entladen, 20 Meter.
Das sind diese zwei Euro-Paletten
da hinten mit diesen rot-weiß gestreiften
Plastikzäunen.
Und das soll unsere Rampe simulieren.
Diese Übung gilt mit der
Prüfungsfahrt als...
Rampe simulieren ohne Rampe?
Nicht bestanden, wenn ich zum Beispiel
mehr als vier Korrekturzüge brauche.
Wenn der Anhänger nicht
parallel an der Rampe steht und wenn der Anhänger
nicht innerhalb eines Meters an der Rampe steht.
Das würde ich dann ganz gerne erstmal
vorfahren. Das heißt vormachen.
Danach erkläre ich das Ganze.
Und dann geht es auch schon los.
Aha.
Bevor ich das jetzt natürlich abgebe,
überprüfe ich das Ganze.
Stehe ich annähernd gerade an der Rampe.
Oh Leute, ich muss ja sagen, ich glaube,
ich hoffe, da kommt der so. Das ist glaube ich
eines der langweiligsten Beiträge, die ich
bisher bei Lohnt-sich-das gesehen habe.
Ich meine, da passiert ja gar nichts.
Außer, dass sie langsam rückwärts
fahren mit dem LKW.
Dann würde ich sagen,
sie fangen an.
Hä?
Der LKW steht doch schon gerade da?
Oder verstehe ich das jetzt nicht?
Also das heißt im Endeffekt ist die Aufgabe
jetzt gerade weiter gerade zu fahren.
Oder was wie? Hä?
Und dann rechtzeitig zu stoppen.
Ach, ne!
Ok, verstehe. Ne, ne, ne, ne.
Ok, so einfach ist das doch nicht.
Oh, die Musik!
Ich halte die Spannung kam aus, Leute.
Schauen wir uns das an.
Sowas von parallel.
Exzellent!
Prinzip ist auch verstanden. Top!
Und dann haben sie den praktischen Teil
für den ersten Tag schon mal geschafft.
Und ich hoffe ja auch, dass es ein bisschen Spaß gemacht hat.
Ok, sehr gut.
Natürlich musst du da Ja sagen. Kannst du nicht sagen,
Alter, ich will den Scheiß hinter mich bringen.
Mahlzeit.
Mit dem ersten Bundeswehr-Gehalt
habe ich erstmal meine Mama gepackt
und habe gesagt, jetzt gehen wir erstmal richtig essen,
ohne auf der Karte auf den Preis zu gucken.
Gute Idee.
Brezel.
Keine Brezel. Für mich ist es Brezel.
Das ist doch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Kannste gar nichts zu sagen.
Das ist doch wirklich nicht schlecht.
Alter, soweit bis jetzt, alles gut?
Also bei mir bleibt zu viel Netto.
Vom Brutto übrig.
Einfach zu viel.
Keine Sozialabgaben zahlen muss.
Als Soldat bin ich tatsächlich nicht
krankenversicherungspflichtig.
Das übernimmt bei der Bundeswehr
komplett die Bundeswehr selbst.
Aber was ich nicht machen kann,
ich kann jetzt nicht einfach mir einen Arzt,
einen Hausarzt aussuchen und dahingehen,
sondern ich muss dann tatsächlich
zu einem Tropenarzt.
Wir haben einen Unterrichtsraum.
Ich muss ehrlich zugeben, ich mache Theorie nicht so gerne.
Ich bin mehr der Praxismänn.
So, Mahlzahlen.
Guck mal mal Licht an.
Damit sie nicht einschlafen.
Ach, vormittags fahren sie Lkw,
nachmittags wird dann gelernt.
Das machst du Theorie nicht so gerne.
Wie kannst du das gestalten, dass das nicht so langweilig wird?
Tatsächlich versuche ich da dann aufzugehen.
Das ist schwierig.
Und dann stehe ich da vorne
und dann schaue ich mich die ganzen Fahrschüler an
und dann denke ich mir so,
da muss man irgendwie was ändern,
dass die nicht so leer reinschauen.
Wir haben heute ein Technikthema.
Und wenn ich dann merke, die machen begeistert mit
und hören mir zu und haben lächeln,
dann ist das natürlich irgendwie fast schon wie ein
Entertainen in diesem Moment.
Und das macht mir dann auch Spaß.
Ich ziehe mich jetzt um.
Schöne Wohnungspreise.
Morgen geht es mal wieder weiter mit der Uniform.
1400 Euro.
Ich habe einen wundervollen Mann.
Hallo mein Schatz.
Wie war dein Tag?
Super.
Sieht sofort, der Tag war super.
Sieht man ihm direkt an.
Ich habe mir jetzt so einen Traum.
Mein Mann hat ja noch drei Söhne in Kroatien.
Die besuchen wir immer im Urlaub.
Mein Mann und ich hätten uns immer so ein bisschen
in der Eigentumswohnung in Kroatien kaufen.
Für später.
Und dass dann auch was da bleibt.
Für die Kinder natürlich.
Das ist immer der schwierigste Teil.
Er hat schlechte Laune.
Checkt, dass gefilmt wird.
Super, alles toll.
Ja, aber das, was netto übrig bleibt,
ist doch wirklich so um die 3500 Euro.
Kannst du dir das mal vorstellen?
Ja.
Das ist wirklich so um die 3500 Euro.
Kannst du dich echt nicht beschweren.
Das ist mehr als die meisten sonst verdienen.
Oh, Torzmusik.
Ich komme zum nächsten Extremsport.
Extrem Couching.
Cringe Joke.
Jawoll, super.
Spannung pur.
Jogginganzug auf der Couch sitzen.
Das war neben der Heirat mit meinem Mann
die beste Entscheidung meines Lebens.
Das ist wichtig, dass sie das jetzt gefilmt haben
mit diesem Jogginganzug auf der Couch.
Das hat sich auf alle Fälle gelohnt.
Und ich bin so dankbar darüber, diese Chance
auch bekommen zu haben.
Und das auch durchgezogen zu haben.
Und auf alle Fälle hat es sich für mich gelohnt.
Also 3400 Euro.
Ja, ist aber
300.
Das haben viele Leute
auch mit deutlich
auf dem Papier besser bezahlten Jobs nicht.
Eben weil die mehr Steuern und Abgaben
und alles bezahlen müssen. Das ist echt in Ordnung.
Kann man nicht sagen.
Kommt man gut mit klar.
Danke euch, dass
ihr mich heute begleitet habt.
Für weitere Videos.
Ja, jetzt nicht.
1400 Euro Wohnen.
Ja, Wohnungspreise sind übertrieben teuer
mittlerweile.
Das Schöne ist,
dass ich das nicht bezahlen muss.
Da bin ich echt sehr
dankbar.
Ich bin sehr dankbar.
Das war's.
Bis später, macht's gut.